youtube
has temporarily suspended stephen
crowder from
uploading live streaming and they've
also
permanently demonetized him once again
so
we knew that a while ago because of this
controversy with a vox personality
stephen crowder was removed from the
partner program for those aren't
familiar i assume most of you are he is
a very prominent conservative
commentator and comedian
and it seems now that they're coming
after him for
investigative reporting and that seems
to be
just about it he was accused of hate
speech recently and youtube said no
that's not the issue
they're taking down certain videos that
they deem to be deceptive
now here's where it gets crazier crowder
did an
update on a different channel explaining
what was going on
and that got removed as well they
claimed that it was
circumventing a ban and that is
absolutely not true
i've spoken with people at google i know
the rules i know exactly
how all the rules they claim every
guideline they say
steven crowder did not break that rule
with his update video and they still
took his video down gave him a warning
and they're claiming he's trying to
circumvent the ban
we'll get into this and i'll break it
all down this is huge because
look crowder is not
alex jones or milo he is a very high
profile mainstream
conservative personality and comedian
and his show
is is absolutely not like those these
these other personalities who have been
banned
now i'm not saying anyone deserves to be
banned but this is serious so we're
gonna get into all this
joining us today of course is friend of
the show daniel turner i think you
should just introduce yourself i wanna
get your
title wrong yeah no thanks for having me
back daniel turner and i
run a uh i founded an energy advocacy
group called power the future and it is
great to be back here with you guys so
thanks for having me
we were gonna well one of the things we
will talk about was gonna be like this
tax program from joe biden the mileage
tax the energy
stuff they're doing and then this
crowder stuff you know kicks off and
this is probably one of the biggest
stories
in social media censorship in a long
time because i think youtube
absolutely is lying about what's going
on what they're telling the press so
we're gonna get into this of course
ian's hanging out what up guys ian
crossland coming at ya
good to see you dale nice to see you and
of course me in the corner pushing
buttons
that's my jab well considering
the um the the purge is upon us
and we've been talking about the purge
for some time we have a very incredible
sponsor today
and uh i'm i'm really really grateful
ladies and gentlemen in the link below
you will see a
a link to stronger bones in life.com
this is biotrust ageless multi-collagen
this is the stuff that helps make up
your joints your hair your skin your
nails
and uh you know they want me to say in
these ads they always say
that it's it's gonna make your skin
supple and youthful and i'm like okay
well you know the ladies may
very very well think that's very
important for me i am
uh an athlete i i skate and i take
i take my health seriously so i use this
stuff biotrust is really really great
it's odorless it's tasteless you just
mix it right it doesn't clump or
anything like that
and uh it's it's really really important
if you look i'm 35
i still like skating my knees are
probably just ripped to shreds at this
point
biotrust is is great no artificial
sweeteners
they say uh it's unflavored and of
course it just easily mixes
they say if you go to stronger bones in
life.com
you can get 51 off while supplies last
and uh you know normally i have a bunch
of talking points pulled up but let's
just
let's just tell you about collagen for a
second it makes your skin healthy and
supple and gives you that youthful look
makes your hair healthy and young
looking well i don't have that problem i
don't have hair
supports joint flexibility strengthen
nails teeth and gums
promote strong healthy muscles tendons
and ligaments promote stronger bones
supports digestive health promotes
healthy appetite management
i'm i'm down for this stuff and this
stuff is fantastic so again go to
strongerbonesandlife.com the link is
in the description below and you can get
51 off they also have this service where
you for life you get health coaching
from this company so again check it out
strongerbonesnlife.com seriously thank
you to biotrust for being a sponsor of
the show especially after talking about
censorship
and of course go to timcast.com and
become a member
because now we're talking about
censorship and
listen with stephen crowder getting hit
so hard by youtube
over what i can absolutely say is is
bunk bs
it's only a matter of time and i keep
seeing from people they're like oh tim's
never gonna get banned it's never gonna
happen
my my facebook's already gone so we're
we're gonna make uh
for for my other youtube channels tim
cass and tim cass news
youtube booted me from the monetization
program for
simply talking about what happened on
january 6th that was it they said you're
out you're gone
i did not express any opinions for it
forgets i was just like here's what's
happening at the capitol this is crazy
here's what we're seeing this is
breaking news
well breaking news is not allowed in the
case of steven crowder he did
investigative reporting they called it
deceptive
they took his videos down they gave him
a strike he can't upload it is going to
happen
anti-establishment personalities even if
you think their milk toast
are going to get axed because we are in
a very serious culture so again
go to timcast.com become a member and
you'll get exclusive
access to members only segments or you
get access to exclusive members only
segments we have cassandra fairbanks the
other night jeremy hambly of the
quartering
we'll have another one tonight and we're
actually expanding this website going to
be producing a whole bunch of new
content so uh absolutely go to
timcast.com become a member because in
the event that we get axed
and maybe what in six months or a year
it's a real possibility that's where
you'll be able to find us and we're
gonna be building something outside of
youtube
don't forget to like share subscribe hit
the notification bell
and we should uh jump into this first
story i'm gonna take some of that
collagen before i get too deep in i like
to put this stuff in my coffee and i've
been waiting patiently
he's like he's reaching his hand give me
a little bit it makes it creamy
and when you say that it's powderless
and odorless it really is like
super pure i'm so glad they don't add
any like
color or weird food colorings to it i
know
i put in my smoothies and then it like
it really does feel like you've added
some kind of cream to the smoothie it
makes it like just creamier
thank you bio trust and everyone that
empowers ian does put in his coffee
every day
it's so good it mixes with the coconut
like incredibly you made a weird drink
like peanut butter
cow peanut butter coconut powder
concoction coconut water i love it
collagen all right ladies and gentlemen
let's talk about this uh this story
because this is this is getting to me
man
uh first the first store we have is from
the verge youtube has removed steven
crowder from its partner program
indefinitely
they say he'll be back in a week but
without youtube ad revenue
why no seriously when you get a strike
on youtube you don't get removed from
the partner program
you just get told hey you gotta strike
you can't upload for a week you can't
live stream
why did they remove him from the partner
program to take away his revenue
see that is not legitimate in my opinion
and i don't know if you know crowder
would agree with me or if he's gonna
appreciate it
they're they're they're just trying to
remove him and they're gonna find any
reason
and we got more stores i'm trying to go
through these quickly the verge says
two weeks ago after youtube revealed its
definition of hate speech was so narrow
that it couldn't remove a wildly racist
tirade for being wildly racist
what is this the verge is this an
opinion piece or is this fact-based news
you see this is the problem with media
that's why channels like crowders are
important so why shows like ours are
important
they're giving you their opinion as the
opener because they don't report the
news they never did
they say we wondered out loud what it
would take for youtube to stop promoting
conservative commentator
stephen crowder as an official youtube
partner and allowing him to profit from
those tirades notice
they just say conservative that's it
ladies and gentlemen they're not saying
far right anymore
the the overton window is shifting but
it's very interesting they no longer
need to say you're far right you're
getting banned now it's just
he's a conservative they should remove
them from the partner program that's it
they say today we have a partial answer
youtube has officially suspended stephen
crowder's main channel from youtube's
partner program indefinitely
which includes removing his ability to
run ads it's also banning him from
uploading videos for a full week
after his latest infraction a now
removed video
that reportedly challenged the
legitimacy of the vote in nevada
youtube is a policy against false claims
the election was stolen full stop
lies or miss framing say the least the
policy that youtube has as was explained
to me
by youtube is that two criteria must be
met
you must say something specific about
the election
and you must say something specific
about donald trump together
crowder did a video where he
investigated voter addresses
and sent people people to those
locations in those videos he
never says anything about the overall
implications of the election
and even said in an update video he
couldn't anyway he doesn't have the
evidence in fact
he even pushed back on mike lindell
saying mike lindell's claims about
dominion are wrong someone gave him
wrong information
so what youtube is claiming about what
crowder did is illegitimate
and and even if it was true that he did
one video where he said this
why take him out of the partner program
now here's where it gets absolutely
insane
crowder put up a video explaining what
was going on
he put it on instagram and he put it on
his other youtube channel
crowder bits because he's got like 855
000 subscribers there
youtube took that video down and issued
a warning saying that he was circum
trying to circumvent his ban
all right i'm going to break something
down for everybody i know i'm i'm going
we got people here to hang out and talk
but i've got to explain all this
i had a conversation you may know this
we had alex jones on the show
alex jones said something a lot of
people misheard what he said including
myself
and it didn't matter youtube didn't care
they said well it was bad enough
and they removed that episode with alex
jones and michael malus from this
channel
issued a warning and i talked to them on
the phone for quite some time and they
refused to reinstate it i said we could
take out that little tiny
one second snippet we could take it out
maybe put it back up and they said
no and i said okay i'm gonna have him
back on the show then
we're gonna do it again and we did and i
said
in the event you guys give me a strike
what does that mean for my other
channels
and i was told by youtube so long as the
content
is different from what you do on these
channels
it is fine and i said okay tim cast irl
is a conversational show with guests
where we go over news stories
my other channels are me and my personal
rants and monologues
is that substantially different and i
was told yes
they're not the same thing they're
different channels for a reason and i
said okay
well that means that's what i want to
know because if you give me a strike on
this channel
i can still keep producing on my other
channels right then i'm willing to take
that risk we're going to have them back
on the show and we did
and it did well because i'm not going to
a lot of people were like oh tim
tim is giving up in censorship i'm like
no as soon as they did it i was like
i called him right back up and said guys
come back on the show we're not doing
this
now what they're doing with crowder
crowder does a show
on his main channel that's produced
there's multiple people involved
there's microphones they're sitting in
chairs and they have cameras and he's
sitting at a desk and he's wearing his
you know his outfit show he's got his
holster on and all that stuff
it is it is produced and set up on
crowder bits
he filmed a video on his cell phone
explaining what was going on
content that was 100 percent
substantially different
from his produced show they took that
video down and gave him a warning that
means he does it again
they're gonna give him a strike that is
illegitimate
youtube is not issuing legitimate
strikes against
or or warnings or whatever against
crowder 100
and i have a i have a feeling it has
something to do
with media matters because they put out
this story where they said after being
suspended from youtube stephen crowder
announces his plan to evade it
via his other youtube channel i'm not
going to go into great details but i'm
going to vaguely mention something very
interesting that's been going on
that was going on for some time we had a
video that media matters targeted
and made false claims about for some
reason that video got demonetized
so i contacted contacted youtube and i
said why is this video demonetized and
they said
seems to be an error don't worry we will
monetize it for you
and they did and then there was an
update i guess on this media matters
piece and then also i noticed the video
was demonetized again
and then i reached back out to google
and said oop that's strange we'll fix it
again
it happened twice there was a back and
forth somebody at these activist
organizations knows people at google or
youtube and they go in and they're
screwing with channels
so when i see youtube say oh stephen
crowder broke the rule
he didn't actually break because they
laid it out for me they sent
everyone an email youtube sent me an
email said here's the specific criteria
you would have to say in order to get a
strike on your channel crowder never
broke those rules
so you know what you're telling us
youtube that there's literally nothing
we can do
if you want to take us down you will lie
and you will do it and then what we see
from all these news organizations
they say well crowder was taken down
because he violated the policy where he
claimed x y and z
they claim that because youtube said the
policy was violated
that affirms that crowder did something
wrong he did not
if youtube tells me you can't you can't
drink bottled water on your show
and then i say okay i won't and then
they give me a strike anyway claiming i
did
the medial report tim poole got taken
down for drinking bottled water on his
show even if i didn't
that's what they're doing it's only a
matter of time and
i tell you this people are saying oh
tim's too milk toast he's not going to
get centered he's not going to get
banned or whatever
we had alex jones and michael mouse on
the show and they took it down and i
immediately called them and brought them
back because i'm not going to bend the
knee to
lies and manipulations and just
unreasonable
actions unprofessional behavior from
from from youtube
if you've got a problem with something
one of my guests says and i offer to
snip that out
that is me going well above and beyond
my own principles because i think we
should be able to have that conversation
up as it is
but i'm willing to recognize youtube has
this platform and i say okay what's
what's the best thing we can do to make
sure 99.99 of this gets out
fine i'll obey that rule but i'm going
to launch timcast.com and we're going to
talk about what we want to talk behind
you this members only pay wall to
protect ourselves from for in the event
youtube does take us down
facebook removed me from the
monetization program for simply covering
the news
stephen crowder is suspended for a week
and removed from the partner program
for simply sending out reporters to
track claims about voter regularity that
was it
he did not make any claims and now here
we are
rant over i suppose no it's
a necessary rant you know i would love
to know
who is on who is receiving the same
wrath from youtube
on the other side of the spectrum right
i mean there have been amazing
allegations for four years about
uh president trump as a as a puppet of
of vladimir putin right there there have
been out and out lies
from what we would consider
quote-unquote the left is there any
leftist group as big as stephen crowder
who has been kicked off the platform for
these types of
violations of service no only small
progressives have been banned
there have been many of them smaller
channels and they shouldn't have been
banned either
i 100 defend the right of all of the
socialists democratic socialists
progressives communists
who produce on youtube and i've seen
some of the channels that got removed on
the left
and i don't see a legit legitimate
reason as to why they were banned
it seems like what youtube is trying to
do is create a mono culture
they're trying to force everyone into a
i don't want to say center left i don't
necessarily want to say far left
homogenous
a homogeneous establishment democrat
left position
getting rid of crowder is an assess is
necessary for them to pull off something
like that
and i tell you i'm not i'm not big into
conspiracies but they just came out
and made claims about why they removed
crowder's content and i
actually having privy information
speaking to google know
they are these statements are just not
true the claims made against them
not true here we go i'd like to add i so
you know i built mines i was one of the
founder co-founders of mines and i
helped design
and construct the website real quick for
those that aren't familiar minds is
another social media platform
it's got it can host videos you can post
things so i'd ethically build out the
terms of service like how are we gonna
how we're gonna adjudicate
user violations of our terms basically
and i was an administrator and
what i realized pretty early on is you
don't ban people
you ban the channel if the channel is in
violation
assume nothing about the people because
that person can make another channel and
if that new channel doesn't violate you
don't mess with it
so that them going after steve is
effed it's messed up you don't target
individuals that makes no sense
your terms specifically target channels
not people
so the thought that he would make
another channel and do something that
doesn't violate terms and still get it
taken down is insane to me
this is why i'm saying they're targeting
him in his business because
as i stated the rules are if you have
two channels i'll try and make this
clear you have two channels and one of
them
is videos about dogs and one of those
videos about cats and your videos about
dogs gets taken it's it's a strike
because a dog you know kind of slipped a
butt or something like oh yeah
it's it's inappropriate and you put up a
video about a cat
that's supposed to be allowed because
it's a different form of content
if crowder uploads something that's not
his show he's not commenting on the news
he's simply saying hey guys here's an
update as to what's going on
they are screwing with him that's it
they're they're
they're they're targeting him it's
unfair and i'm sick of the butt my
private business
argument from all of these establishment
crony types it's just not the case
we need balance and we need
representation for
people of different ideas different
ideologies and different perspectives
if they get rid of crowder crowders fans
don't go away
they get angry they go other places so
you know what in that regard maybe
youtube will absolutely [ __ ] itself
by doing this but
the problem is that alphabet google
subsidizes youtube so that other video
platforms
can't be as successful and that keeps a
stranglehold on the market
for channels like like minor everyone
else's but more importantly
youtube is first in best dressed
and the biggest the second biggest
search engine i believe in the world
and it is used by everybody we ask only
that those rules be applied fairly
and that the contracts they have people
sign are upheld so i wonder this
if youtube says you must abide by our
community guidelines otherwise we can
ban you
but then they they ban you or strike you
even though you didn't violate those
guidelines i wonder if they're in breach
of their own terms on their end
i wonder if there's a possibility that
you could go after them because we have
seen strategies like this before
i don't know exactly what uh crowd
around will end up doing i know that his
uh half asian lawyer bill made an
announcement about you know what's
happening the blaze posted it
and for those and i i want to make sure
i give a shout out to crowder but the
best of my ability
they say you can go to
louderwithcrowder.com what is it
lotterycrowder.com
slash mug club or just go to
lotterathcrowderweb.com go to his
website
and if you want to support him as well
if youtube
is going after crowd in such a way that
is illegitimate
do you really think a channel like this
can last much longer after they they
take him down
these it's it's it's the canary in the
coal mine for everybody the way i
explained it a long time ago was
we're standing on this big island these
with cliffs all around
and the waves are just crashing and
eroding at the at one side
sure the far right gets banned this is
what they do is what authoritarians do
say oh nobody likes the far right fringe
weirdo racist and conspiracy theorists
so when they get banned the
establishment types are like i don't
care
then they come for very staunch hardcore
pro-america conservatives
and even regular conservatives are
pointing out like hey that's bad
regular people are going like well i'm
not a fan of those those kind of people
and the left ignores it now they're
coming for regular run-of-the-mill
high-profile mainstream conservative
types people like steven crowder
what's next moderates yeah and then
we're then we're gone
i'm pretty critical of google i have
been since they bought youtube 2007. i
was freaking out i was a youtuber 2006
7. i was like oh well google's bought
about to buy youtube
it's going to get super corporate and
we'll see and google
whoever's running google you guys do an
amazing job at
search algorithms i love your search
your search engine but
i don't think you guys are equipped to
run a social network
you had youtube in 2007 you screwed it
up and then you built google plus which
nobody used when you could have been
using youtube as your social network
that's right
and they got rid of video responses
which was one of the hottest community
building
pieces of tech on the on the website and
and they
they make these heavy-handed it's just a
huge company
i'm not i i don't know i can't get too
critical because i don't work there i
never have
um but it just it saddens me that you
would drag your social network through
the mud like this when you have an
opportunity to build the best one
it's an it's it's a growing cult
infection it's a cult
there's i was trying to find i know
there were a bunch of google execs i
wasn't i was listening clearly
but i was trying to google the uh trying
to google a whole bunch of google execs
who went to the biden administration
trying to find names
but the stories that i'm i'm finding in
this search are all about how the bite
administration will be tougher on big
tech than than the previous
administration
um none of them will well you know i
mean these are questions
we'd like to have legitimate hearings on
this right we've talked about it before
they every now and then get hauled up in
front of congress and
um um zuckerberg is there right with his
really pasty face you know
um and just an awful usually an awful
camera angle which is kind of bizarre
that
no one does a good job on his on his
yeah you know like like framing your
shot a little bit but you got 60 billion
dollars
but it would be curious to get some of
these folks involved to say what is the
how much further does the big tech
censorship get to go before it becomes
like a true just violation of of of
civil liberties of the constitution
we've already seen it egregiously yep
but how much more they
have had so many hearings i i just don't
care anymore they just lie
they lie absolutely i used to watch them
i was like it's really exciting
you know ted cruz is gonna grill jack
dorsey it's gonna be fantastic
and now it's like oh it's the fifth time
huh it's a rerun you know what i mean at
this point i'm not interested in
watching that's a waste of time not
doing anything
uh free i mean i'm obsessed with freeing
the software code of large social
networks if a network
starts getting massive traffic like
becomes part of the commons 100 million
hit users a month i don't know
some arbitrary number but you free their
software code of the
of the social network aspect so that you
can other people can build that same
network
tech other than that i'm always at a
loss of how do they
that's why i don't think they have done
anything about it because if you break
up facebook into multiple companies and
i talked about this last week like
instagram facebook messenger facebook
prime and then zuck owns
the same percentage of all these new
companies nothing's changed he still
commands the
terms of service of all the new
companies he still owns them all so you
can't break it move them
so what but can you i don't think you
can legally do that so what's the real
risk then that people looking for
internet freedom end up on tick tock
which is owned by the communist chinese
oh and there's less there right i mean
it's gonna get it's going to be
worse you know we need decentralized
social media i suppose
yeah we need i don't necessarily think
the blockchain is the answer but i do
think there's great
prospects in in blockchain technology
but we just need and something we've
talked about the show quite a bit is
you know i'm talking about creating an
open source plugin that people can put
on their websites that just networks
websites together
so no one could ban anybody and there's
something called the fetaverse we talk
about a lot which is
it's like a protocol instead of a
website where you can follow someone
from a different you can follow like
john john.com or whatever instead of
instead of following at john you follow
john john.com and you can follow
johnnethgab.com and get all of their
feeds showing up like twitter or other
social media
there's um other than blockchain there's
like r weave which i think mines is
looking into right now bill has been and
like ipfs interplanetary file system and
they they tend to be faster
than the blockchain for stuff like this
sometimes so they're advancing this this
decentralized tech
and i think we'll eventually have
something that can host videos as well
as you next
you uh just mentioned that you thought
i'm sorry that you you just mentioned
biden apparently is going to go harder
on big tech
these are all the articles yeah that i
was looking at you were saying so here's
something funny that's happening right
now
techcrunch reports youtube is testing
hiding dislike
counts on videos i wonder why that might
be
yeah could it be that every single video
that joe biden puts out or that
democrats put out
are just slammed by everyone that's
democracy now what is that
is it a russian bot conspiracy that
people are saying i don't like this
video from joe biden
my question is where are then the
democrats to counteract that
and give an upvote to joe biden they
don't exist no you don't
you know what it is they're still down
in trump's content i think
the people who vote for joe biden don't
pay attention don't watch the news have
no idea what's going on
and they're not going to watch a joe
biden video the trump supporters the
conservatives the moderates the people
who are quote-unquote red-pilled who
have
woken up to the media's lies in the
narrative it's because they're looking
at videos of trump they're watching the
source material on youtube and then
going
i don't like this so youtube now has to
intervene and remove the
dislike button counter it's a matter of
time until they remove the
live views counter as well because there
are times that
they are streaming the the the biden
giving remarks at the white house or
even during the campaign
uh biden is going to sit down with these
activists and you would see in the
bottom left corner
800 people are watching 900 people are
watching
people would circle it and tweet it and
say is this a joke like this is the
the president the most popular president
900 people watching this video and i'm
one of them
right now but listen listen democrats
have always gone for
low information voters and a lot of
people might be like oh here we go
tim paul so biased against democrats
he's right wing no
actually i'm pretty far left politically
it's kind of strange
my problem is you're not going to get me
to say something that's not true all
right i'll tell you something
democrats want to give the right to they
want 16 year olds to have the right to
vote whoa
16 year olds you are not going to
convince me are
high information voters some maybe but
as you get younger and younger
the likelihood of finding a low
information voter goes up
exponentially 16 to young people no but
i but 16 year olds are also eating tide
pods yeah right i mean
no offense to 16 year olds but no
they never did no offense to 16 year
olds
now again one guy did though we can we
can allow the 16 year old to vote
if the 16 year olds can also buy alcohol
buy cigarettes and get drafted
because what i have a problem with when
it comes to these age things isn't i
doing still enjoy my cigarettes every
now and then
right you got to be 21 to smoke now in a
lot of states 18 to get a beer but the
16 year old can vote you
off to war in afghanistan and you're
like wait a second so
what is the age of adulthood and make
everything
that age parents tell them what if what
if the requirement for voting was just
you have to
live on uh you have to have you no
longer
maybe it has to be a job maybe the
requirements are you have a job you have
to be paying taxes yeah you pay taxes
you can vote
taxation requires representation you
should have to have some sort of skin in
the game right
i mean the original constitution was was
they argued about landowners and that
was considered
you know offensive or however you want
to phrase it um
but the idea was skin in the game and if
you are
i'm sorry if this is the the problem
that romney got into back in 12 when he
talked about the 44 percent and we don't
47
and he phrased it terribly but i think
the point he meant to say was
there's a large population of this of
this population of this country
that is on the taking side and so they
will vote
for things to be given to them for free
whether it's stimulus checks
whether it's welfare whether it's free
look at the people voting for free uh
you know uh absolution of their college
loans well i didn't go to college i
don't have any debt
right but but you did and you got a
degree in modern dance and i have to now
pay
welcome my personal life exactly right
so so there is going to be
always a class of people that will vote
for more free stuff for themselves
it has to be skin in the game exactly
that's why kids shouldn't vote
just to bring it back the ultimate point
is democrats like voters who are
on the low information side yet at the
same time these are the same people who
claim to be
more educated i'm sorry i need to
explain something everybody's listening
going to college does not mean you are
more educated i i mean that
and a lot of people confuse going to
university with
being educated you can spend four years
in college and read
almost nothing and just you know squeeze
on by
party hard party hard and just do the
bare minimum
or you could be someone who goes to the
library every day
and reads reads a book every day and
you're substantially more educated than
somebody who just decides to go to
college now
i think there's a correlation between
getting an education and being in
college but in the past
generation or so college seems to be a
big fat waste of time it used to be a
huge opportunity to
have access to books and and stuff but
you don't need that the internet now
yeah yeah if i can go online and learn
whatever i want what's the point of
spending 40 50 grand for it
i will say though if we if we think
about this from a solution-oriented
perspective
maximizing the best outcome for this
country i do believe we need some form
of student loan forgiveness
probably in the form of eliminating
interest rates and at this point saying
pay off your principal you borrow the
money you got to pay it back
maybe maybe within with with inflation
as a
as a standard you know uh interest rate
not
compounded interest or anything like
that but i will point out too for a lot
of these people
on the left who are like we should have
our student loans forgiven
that would be and this is what they
don't understand giving a 50
000 grant to the wealthiest americans
yeah fund the rich so i wanted that what
they want to do i wanted to google this
before i talked about it and some of the
largest endowments in
american university systems harvard has
over 40 billion dollars in endowment
so if you want to talk about student
loan absolution why doesn't harvard kick
in some of their 40
billion dollars which literally just
accrues interest every year they charge
these people seventy thousand dollars a
year
yale has what is it twenty seven billion
dollars uh
yeah sorry thirty billion dollars
stanford twenty seven princeton twenty
five
mit seventeen so if we want to talk
about student loan forgiveness
obviously there has to be reform of the
tuition system because it is being paid
for by the taxpayers
but why doesn't harvard give up some of
their damn money
to pay those guys who have useless i
mean quite honestly
if you have a graduate degree in
critical race theory from harvard
you have a useless degree i'd like to
give a shout out to our good friend will
chamberlain and say
seize the endowments when you say
endowments is that the yearly
like government gives them 30 billion a
year no this is uh you know rich people
who write a 100 million dollar check and
they want to
endow a a a chair in their name or they
want to endow a building or whatever
but harvard's been around for 200 and
something years and they've accrued over
time so that's money sitting in an
account
exactly literally sitting in the bank
just the other day georgetown announced
i got a 100 million dollar grant from
somebody uh
i i forget who 100 million dollar
donation georgetown's going to take that
100 billion dollars they're going to put
it in the bank they're not going to drop
the tuition rate
for any of their students a dime they're
just going to put it in the bank and say
thank you very much
for your money what i can't understand i
know we were supposed to be talking
about youtube
dislike count but i think it's all
related it is i i really do think so
i think that these these people who go
to university think about it for two
seconds
they're told to do it not everybody i
know a lot of you listening probably
went to college you didn't realize it
but there's a lot of people who are like
what should i do and then someone comes
along and says
you're going to take out 50 000 worth of
loans don't worry
you have to do it everybody has to do it
and they go okay i'll do what you say
then they go to college they do as
they're told they rack up all this debt
now they're living in this massive debt
doing as they're told every step of the
way and they're miserable
some people finally realize what's going
on
they'll drop out they'll leave or
they'll realize it after the fact hey
wait a minute that was a big mistake
i screwed myself up by not listening to
myself
now you look at these people these
college educated they say
overwhelmingly vote for for democrats
correlation between those
who don't investigate who don't watch
a biden's speech to see what he actually
has to say and don't watch a trump
speech to see what he has to say
and thus the only people who are
watching bite another people who
actually listen to what he has to say
don't like it hit the dislike button and
then youtube decides
well we got to remove it because it's
making us look good you've come full
circle absolutely i love that
yeah no no you're absolutely right and
and when you get into the college level
the way youtube is removing content
the way universities are removing
content that they don't like the way
they're banning certain clubs banning
certain speakers
heck it wasn't that long ago that people
like ann coulter tried to speak at
berkeley
that it looked like the minnesota riots
and you say
you or you are not being sent off to
d-day right
but you 19-year-old boy can't handle the
fact that a woman whose commentary you
don't like is on your campus
just you know what man up and stay in
your dorm room and say wow that's too
bad i mean that's what i do when a
baseball team is on that i don't like
all the red sox are on tonight well i'm
not going to watch the damn channel
it's right so so not only are they not
exposed to this stuff but it's being
banned from it proactively banned
and on top of that the political stuff
we're banning certain authors now we're
ben not
dr seuss but we're banning parts of
shakespeare there was that op-ed a
little while ago about the like
the undeniable whiteness of shakespeare
or something absurd like that
and you say i don't even think
shakespeare knew he was white because it
was the 1520s in england
he just knew he was shakespeare and and
were banning those types of
who was the dude uh uh from braveheart
that movie's based off of
william wallace yeah i think someone
graffitied a wall in like scotland
saying william wallace wallace was
racist or something
and someone commented i'm pretty sure he
never even saw a black person in his
entire life no i guarantee you he never
did
yeah right i mean it was it was 12 12 uh
13th century yeah you know dude
everybody was racist back then
that was when you were all well they
were more like um xenophobic
yeah afraid of the other yeah because
the the last people they knew who didn't
look like them were the vikings and they
killed everybody
and they stole all their church goods
and they stole all the women
well exactly so take a look at
scandinavia now
oh yeah what happened in that place i
don't know what they are they
they received too many immigrants they
were like the whoa no no no i don't
think these was immigration
like you know you know what's really
fascinating is that i mentioned this the
other day
think about illegal immigrants right now
coming to the u.s
they're willing to climb mountains ride
on the top of trains
make it through 90 miles of desert with
limited supplies because they believe in
that american dream
and look i can respect that that's drive
but you got to come in the proper way
for a variety of reasons we don't want
people going through the desert risking
their lives
and we want to make sure that when they
come here they're they're given real
opportunities if they just come in they
get exploited and it creates whole
you know a lot of problems economically
for many of the migrants
but you take a look at some of these
countries even the united states
the popula it's the it's the it's the uh
domestic population
uh mostly suburban progressives and
liberals
that have become just absolutely weak
and pathetic
you take a look at scandinavia and it is
the overwhelmingly
white uh you know indigenous
of the of the region i suppose you'd
call them who are opening up all these
policies that will erode and eventually
destroy their own their own governments
and i'm i'm speaking specifically about
like you know swede
sweden's policy on their welfare system
for instance is unsustainable unless
they keep bringing in more and more
migrants
now that's not what i'm referring to
that's actually them trying to stem the
bleed
the problem is they wouldn't need to
desperately ask people to come to their
country
if their country was properly run but
you look back at the viki
the vikings they got on boats they went
to england
they stole all them and came back and
they were brutal the vikings were brutal
all the really hot women
that's why apparently they're so
attractive well i was listen
i was told this i was told this joke
when i was in uh
i i think i was told this joke every
every i was in norway sweden and denmark
and they're like you want to hear a
scandinavian joke why are there no
beautiful women in in england and i'm
like why because we stole them all
and i'm like it's a really amazing joke
for a group of people that are like some
of the most
demure and like you know uh i guess
i don't wanna weak willed i suppose
docile seem very calm maybe they're in
the cold all the time so they move
slower
that's because socialism socialism
ultimately will is in a feat
a system and it will it will emasculate
you
i mean i just think that's the root and
social they have been solved socialists
for generations now look and i think
ultimately is it
is it is a defeatist philosophy and it
is a a
weakening philosophy and i think that's
what you get after
you know three generations of
quasi-socialists that's what happens to
you
are you familiar with stras how
generational theory no
so we had uh ben stewart on the show and
has a really fascinating conversation
this is
it's a book called the fourth turning
and they talk about how there's four
seasons every 20 years it's a season
there's
the springtime there's the summer the
autumn and then the winter
and we are about to hit the winter
season so the way it goes at every 80
years
there is a massive upheaval violent war
or something like that right
80 years ago what do we have world war
ii 80 years before that what did we have
civil war 80 years before that what did
we have a revolutionary war
and so they're basically like we're
about to enter this period uh i bring
this up because
everything we're mentioning uh you know
for those who are just tuning in or just
jumping on this segment
we're talking about countries like
scandinavia and you mentioned like after
three generations of
just i guess everything's granted to you
we're with prosperity we we become
weakened
and i want to show you the story from
the new york post and i want to bring
this up pentagon
diversity chief reassigned amid probe of
social media posts
i don't care about this guy being
reassigned i care the pentagon
has a diversity chief i keep hearing
these stories about
diversity inclusivity and equity
liaisons and and
czars and chiefs and officers
why do our businesses have ideological
arms or employees to me i know it's not
identical
but it's no different from the communist
party saying if you want to open a
business in china the communist party
needs to have a position
in your company here in the us they're
like well if you're running this company
you need to give our cult a position in
your company
the pentagon has it now i'm sorry man
we've weakened beyond
it's it's perhaps too late in my opinion
i don't know maybe it's not too late
but the generations that came before us
were not paying attention
and they don't care i've talked to
people in the intelligence community and
they tell me leadership doesn't care
they just want to get home at the end of
the day they want they want to maintain
the status quo
whatever pays the bills they don't care
so this is crazy no it is and and the
role of the pentagon should be to train
and prepare a force to be
lethal and brutal to defend the country
if need be and hopefully that day never
comes
but that's the only diversity and
inclusion they need they need to be as
diverse and inclusive to the point that
they will
destroy any enemy that faces them and
and
the fact that we're pushing these
sociological or or psychological
philosophies that's just runs counter to
the goal
of the military diversity inclusivity
and equity
in terms of the military should be a
diversification of armament
inclusion of different ordinance and
equity in the amounts that they have
across the board to be able to defeat
any threat
not some weird cult-like ideology about
you know training soldiers that the
gadsden flag is racist
and then if somebody has it on their
facebook they got to pull them out of
their their mission in dc yeah military
philosophy is legit but
that's the philosophy of combat and
confrontation not
of how people feel not really i mean
there is the hearts and minds battle
that we're trying to win and maybe some
people think that by doing this we're
gonna
we're gonna get more hearts and minds on
our side but it seems like it's it's
rupturing the system when it doesn't
need to i and i think we've been playing
the military at least has been playing
the hearts and minds game for
20 some odd years i was at state
department long long time ago
um spent time in iraq afghanistan
as part of the hearts and minds war and
for 20 years now we've been saying well
maybe if we just work with the taliban
and build their kids schools and
maybe if we send more of their girls
into jobs trainings
and here we are 20 years later and how
many trillions of dollars more and it's
like and how's that going for us right
we can't get out of afghanistan
even trump couldn't pull out of
afghanistan because the mission isn't
yet accomplished
so maybe the hearts and minds game is
what the military should do maybe the
military should kill all of the enemies
and and i'm sorry to say that and then
what happens after that
that's their problem like if they wanted
to create like a global arm of goodwill
and they wanted to build water systems
and roads and all these countries across
the world
cool but if you drop bombs on a country
it's going to set the whole process back
20 years maybe they should be building
infrastructure roads water
here yeah they should and over there
like just do it
well they just did around the the
capitol for the last two months they
built a great wall
it was as secure as could be none of the
crazy trucks
no trump supporters penetrated the
capital for for months
on end so i mean they kept saying walls
don't work and they built the wall to
keep out
amazing well tom cotton is doing
something about it cotton introduces a
bill to ban
critical race theory teaching in the
military okay
that's fine it's not gonna pass
republicans don't have any power right
now
and what the democrats seem to be doing
right now is
they know they have a very slim majority
and they are pushing as hard as possible
to gain as much power
as possible because they know it won't
last yes come 2022 the republicans will
take the house back
and then they will and probably the
senate in 2022 you think
it's 50 50. yeah are the are there seats
up for
democrats yeah yeah and i think i mean
literally you flip two seats and that's
all that that
matters i mean starting with georgia
right one season yeah starting people
starting with georgia um there's a
there's a re-election there because it
was a temporary seat right so
so yeah i'm but like you i agree with
you 100 they know they have a two-year
window to enact as many things as
possible
obama did the same thing back in 2009
right he passed health care
because he knew he had one shot to do it
they had a super majority they had to
get it done
they got it done and then they lost i'm
not confident
the republicans will be successful i
think there's a lot of people who don't
like the republican party who only voted
republican because trump was something
different he was actually
trying to do things you take a look at
biden right now
did you see that they apparently
rebranded to the biden harris
administration
creepy what is this um i i tweeted about
it and i was like
i was like amazing and inspiring despite
every obstacle from racism sexism to not
even getting a single delegate in the
presidential primary
kamala harris is proving that nothing
will stand in her way and she will
eventually become president
she didn't get a single delegate and now
they're slowly inching towards making
her the president
and it's right there if i didn't get any
delegates in 2008 i don't remember
i don't know he was up against he was a
nobody in that running though he was one
of the worst guys on stage
in 2000 that's a disgusting great
question how how soon did he drop
you know and i was paying attention
those days also but um
he wasn't i think hillary was was
obama's biggest competition in 2008
bernie's
no not bernie sanders yeah i was pre
bernie and i'm sure biden and there were
probably like three or four other folks
out there who
ran who dropped out pretty quickly um
was that also um got zero delegates
a couple of zero delegates a couple of
losers then biden got
all this free press being the vp yeah
and they got made for they would make
fun of him be like
oh joe shut up you know those memes
where like it shows
joe saying something stupid and obama's
like oh yeah that's that was real
i think i think critical race theory in
the military is
it's the demise of the military dude
it's interesting what you need to
understand about critical race theory is
that it's not actually a theory of
anything no
it's basically just one person going
i've decided that
uh water bottles are racist and does
everybody agree
and then someone goes i don't think it's
racist well then you're a racist for
denying it yeah
that's all they do is there's like no
right fine racist
oh god ibrahim x kendi the guy who wrote
that that book
um is it how to be an anti-racist said
that that one of the
he said the heartbeat of racism is
denialism
by denying your racism is a sign of your
racism
and that that is kafka right that whole
that whole kafka book that the trial
was about that like if you admit it
you're guilty if you deny it well only
someone who would have done it would
deny it you're guilty
and so so kafka how many hundred dozens
of years ago 100 years ago was like well
this is where we are headed
and that's what critical race theory is
you are racist intrinsically by your
race
and if you deny it it's only because
that is a sign of your racism and there
you go
i think we did that with witches in the
salem witchcraft they throw them in the
water and
if she's a witch she'll float no no no
okay that was a joke but they're funny
those guys if she weighs as much as a
duck
yes right yeah what else weighs ducks
that's right so if she floats and she
weighs as much as a duck which means
she's made of wood
it's a witch is it that they would burn
them alive and if they didn't burn then
they were a witch
i always they when the knight said a
duck and that the the man said
who are you so wise in the ways of
science i
i reply often on twitter with that when
people like solar panels are renewable
forever and i'm like who are you
so wise in the ways i love that line
i guess this is this is an issue of
people who vote when there's no skin in
the game
yeah you know and so the challenge is
you know uh someone asked me about
they're like well you know you know back
in the day
when people would vote they had to be
landowners because it was about racist
white slave owners blah blah and i was
like i thought the idea was that they
didn't have ids
and so it was like you had to actually
live there and be able to prove you
lived there to vote
and so land ownership proved not only
were you a member of the community
proved you lived there
and that you had skin in the game and a
stake in what this vote represented
the issue now is and i'm not i'm not
saying i i'm actually a fan of
like universal suffrage people having
the right to vote well i should say
universal i don't know if that implies
it could be anybody like dog's vote or
something
but uh i i think you know there's a
people should have the right to vote
we're in a different system
but now we have people who will like
move to new york and then after like a
month they're eligible to vote vote for
something ridiculous
and then a few months later back oh man
this is awful i regret that and then
i'll leave
and they just leave the place worse off
there needs to be something
staking your vote like and and you in
this community where
you know that what you do will impact
you otherwise people can come and vote
and
leave yeah like local like waiting a
couple years before you can vote locally
that got brought up a couple weeks ago i
like that idea and
yeah and so then what happens is we
remember like in this past election
there are a lot of people who are like
i think it was andrew yang got in
trouble because he said he was going to
go on down to georgia
and help the democrats win and people
are like yo and
the georgia republicans were like if you
move here and try to vote yeah i'm not
going to do that i'm not doing that
but it was actually a big issue because
people can move all over the place
andrew yang should run as a republican
well i think he can win 2024
as a democrat for mayor of new york oh
yeah
good luck andrew after having tweeted
multiple times about like leaving the
city and now he hated living in new york
and
and he uh i mean he's always had a condo
there or something but he lived outside
of new york and
now he sees this as a viable opportunity
and he's like yeah maybe i'll work okay
mayor of new york's better mayor of new
york yeah
republican president because they want a
populist the republicans love
well p the people that went for trump
love a good populist like
energetic fireball of a personality and
yang i think is
you know he was he was he's got more
muralist appeal yeah without a doubt
but but going back to the voting thing i
i agree with you in that
we establish thresholds for things for a
purpose and by lowering the threshold by
by dumbing it down to put it
pejoratively
does not do society a service so we've
made it so easy to drive now
right we got rid of a lot of the driving
exam
parallel parking is no longer part of
the driving exam in new york city
wow yeah the the k-turn is no longer
part well
are we making our roads better it's like
well no we're allowing more people to
drive well i don't want more people to
drive i want
driving to be something that you
actually can prove that you can do
same with exams same with citizenship to
a certain extent
and i think voting is the same way i
don't want to lower the threshold down
to get
the lowest common dominator in i think
we have to keep standards high
look we talk about this with do you want
your medical doctor to be someone who is
like well i i you know i did the
multiple choice test
well maybe i want your exam to be a
little bit harder than that if you're
going to operate on my
eyes right maybe you should pass a
certain threshold and we've lowered the
threshold down for voting to the point
that
like you said you can show up to a state
same day and say i live here now
with no id no covert passport though
that's a little different
but with no id with no proof of anything
i want to vote in this election okay you
can vote why because
that's fairness that's that's not
service guarantees citizenship
are you familiar with that starship
troopers yeah
yeah everyone brings that up see i don't
i don't know if i agree with that
concept but it's interesting it's an
interesting concept concept and uh um
i guess the the author got called a
fascist for implying that you you'd have
to serve the community or the country
in order to have the right to vote in
that country i don't agree with that
it's but it's skin in the game of
something right now
i think i think there has to be a
standard
required for voting and it was funny i
think i got accused by leftists of
saying you know like tim poole thinks
that
it should be harder to vote and i'm like
i mean it should be
to a certain degree there should be a
standard to vote some kind of thing
where
we don't want people to be laying you
know in on their couch
covered in grease stuck to their sofa
because they've been sitting there for
six months
and they're like i don't want to work
and then they get a letter in the mail
and they're like they pick it up
you know their mom throws it at him and
they're like mail in ballot
and they open it up and they're like i'm
gonna vote for this guy and send it in
meanwhile there's a guy who's overseas
got his leg blown off in afghanistan his
vote is now negated by this person who
does nothing
and he's risking everything so i feel
like there's got to be at least
you have to get up and go vote yeah and
maybe something more
my general idea is if people want to
vote they need to
choose to get up and go vote and we even
talked about this i think ian and i
agree we should remove party affiliation
from from ballots because what happens
is people show up and they're like
r d and then you end up with a bunch of
wackos running the government
which is where we're at right now well
yeah and i think
getting rid of lowering the voting age
the reason why i'm opposed to it is and
i said kind of cruelly like 16 year olds
eat tie pods and and of course i'm
i'm joking but we used to we used to
understand that like
with age somehow came experience came
wisdom came knowledge and and that can
only
i'm not necessarily but it's more likely
to have more knowledge as an older
person than as a younger person
because of time right because just
because of time
then that's an interesting point because
that still could be aegis there's very
wise 16 year olds maybe somebody started
working the family business when they
were seven
so aptitude test how do you do it you
know how do you make sure that people
would be cool if a kid and no offense to
16 year olds i know you don't feel like
a kid but legally your kid until you're
18.
um could take a special test if you're
under 18 and you wanted to vote you
could go apply
take a civic example yeah yeah i want to
clarify that tide pod thing
nobody actually ate tide pods it was a
meme but one kid as part of the meme
put the tide pod in his mouth as a joke
and then his saliva broke it oh no
oh and as soon as he tasted it he
and aspirated to some of the pot and
then spit it out did he live
yeah he's okay permanently it scarred a
ton of his lung tissue
he was not trying to eat the tide pod he
was jokingly
putting in his mouth yeah these things
are dissolved by water like almost
instantly yeah and then he went and like
inhaled
a bit of it don't put tight pots in
yeah don't pretend like you're gonna
hurt yourself yeah yeah so let's let's
talk about the kind of leadership
we deserve and that uh we need and that
we get
from the daily mail biden's dog major
bites
another government employee on white
house grounds while out for a walk
three weeks after biting white house
security guard
i'm i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna pass it off
to you daniel because you're uh you've
you've trained dogs
i take it it just drives me absolutely
crazy i have two right now um
i have fostered several dogs but um my
better half has fostered
i would say in the hundreds he's been
doing it for 30 years right i mean
fostering dogs you have them for
you know sometimes three weeks four
weeks five weeks he rehabilitates them
to get them to a good point
so that they will be adopted into a
permanent home
the fact that a 75 year old
fairly senile man was given a
six-month-old german shepherd
male puppy as a prop right like like the
i i am mad at the bidens for doing this
i'm mad at his handles for doing this
but i am angriest at the foster group
because
the reason why there are so many dogs in
kent and in fosters right now uh
in in uh um being held in pens
is because they are so stringent on who
fosters a dog
and they are pretty strict right that
you you can't get a dog pretty easily
but this guy somehow got one and he got
a difficult one like german shepherd
they are wonderful dogs but they are by
nature protective dogs they are
guardians and they are
alphas they're dominants right and joe
biden is no alpha no matter how many
aviators he wears
the leather jackets the rhetoric the
come on man i'll come on
man i'll challenge you to push-ups right
now that is all bluster and a dog is not
as
stupid as the american press corps and
that dog is like
well guess what you know be itch i am
the
alpha of this family joe biden's not
disciplining me
jill is not this hunter is off doing
something else i am in charge of this
family and that is why he is biting
and that's sad two people yes okay that
you guys can create putting the dog down
no from my experience of a dog in
multiple states i
i'm pretty sure it's the law in dc let
me tell you something
when you are training a dog especially a
german shepherd
if you are too weak the dog will not
obey you
german shepherds are particularly tough
these are these are soldier dogs man
that's why you know cops using these
these are some of the most
uh intelligent and strong dogs
joe biden 78 year old man being given
these dogs and you were right as a prop
yeah i was a prop because he wanted to
look cool they made a big deal about the
fact that trump didn't have a dog and
what man doesn't have a dog in the white
house the white house always has dogs
obama got a dog
a portuguese water dog a little dog
right but
little portuguese no offense all you
portuguese water dogs out there who are
listening to tim cast
um but this was a prop this was to make
him look cool and to get that talking
point he has a rescue dog
and i i think it does a lot of damage to
the rescue dog community because it
scares people but he should not have
been given this dog
you can be 75 and foster a german
shepherd puppy
if you have been doing this your whole
life
if you know what you are doing if it's
your full-time job and if you are
retired yeah and i'm lucky that i work
from home i live on this farm but you
know what a
my older blue healer which is a great
dog but also is a guardian dog it's a
cattle dog it is
it is an alpha dog he's a year and a
half which is in dog years you know
17 18 and he sometimes i will have to
hold him down and yell it because he's
like i'm in charge you know what i'm
gonna do this and
and he will push and you have to push
back if you want to
and now that's why my dog which is a
interesting breed an aggressive
not aggressive a happy excitable breed
but it is as docile it could be that
people come over and they're like oh my
gosh your dog is so sweet
that's not a friggin accident my dog is
sweet because it takes
constant work and this poor major can i
have can i have
major biden by the way i will take major
off your hands because this dog is now
probably going to get put down as a
vicious dog and it's not he's got a
stupid handler
what if we send in the dog whisperer
who's that guy caesar caesar milan why
so biden is on another reality show
all right you know let's do it dude
humans humans
uh are being given a really bad name
lately because i was talking about this
in one of my earlier segments
there's this really really awful video
where a 65 year old asian woman is
walking to church
and some guy just brutally beats her
just a stomping on her head can't even
watch it it's disgusting
it's horrifying and these two security
guards i just watch and then one of them
walks over and closes the door
even after the attacker leaves some
people are like oh you know he didn't
want to the
security guards couldn't intervene
because they could get in trouble or be
liable and people were like dude
the attacker leaves and the woman is
writhing on the ground and like raising
her hand
and they come and close the door and
walk away they could have got on their
phones and called somebody then do
anything
and i'm sitting here like humans are
are doing really dumb stuff right now
and animals are starting to look a whole
lot better see this incident with german
shepherd
joe biden was given this dog it was it
was a prop as you said they were like
look at this guy with this dog
and then the dog does dog stuff and now
it's just new another news cycle
and i'm thinking about this story with
this this asian lady
and even a rooster even a rooster
will set will run and fight predators to
protect
chickens after it warns the chickens it
will make a certain call and the
chickens will run in
which is great but we have people these
days that are are incapable they're weak
and i guess what i'm trying to say is
when you have a culture of people who
just stand there and
watch a 65 year old woman be brutally
beaten on the street and they won't do
anything and a rooster will
something's going good with chicken
society it's not going good with our
society
because we vote for joe biden i i don't
mean we here on the show but 80 million
people vote for this guy
and then he ends up being given this dog
he can't control
i'll tell you this man if he can't
control the german shepherd how
is he going to control putin or kim
jong-un
we are not doing well for ourselves when
we're not electing
even someone as capable as a rooster to
protect us yeah exactly
that's that's that's extremely that is
extremely well said
society is going better than america
yeah yeah
chicken city and you know i'm sure they
got the six month
puppy and german shepherd puppies are
adorable as all puppy most puppies are
but they do grow up and it's like people
who have kids and they're like well this
will be fun that's why i hate that mtv
show
a teen mom because i think it glorifies
how cool it is to be 15 or 16 and have a
kid
and i think it does a great disservice
because kids do grow up and if they
don't grow up in a good environment
and i'm not i'm just saying in a good
environment we'll leave it at that
and hunter oh not hunter biden well he
didn't grow up in a great environment
but major biden the dog has now had
three years
not in a good environment with an
undisciplined environment
and look at where he is does that maybe
explain hunter biden
well you know there's a there's an awful
lot of going on in hunter biden and
and i will just say this and it's going
to be a little bit more realistic and i
apologize but i'm just going to throw it
out there
the laptop stuff is bad the chinese
firms are bad the ukrainian firms is bad
that you are sleeping with your dead
brother's wife
and her sister simultaneously while you
are fathering a child
with a stripper you are a bad person
i mean i have lots of sisters-in-law i
couldn't
imagine well for a couple reasons who
raised but i couldn't imagine
my brother dying and being like you know
what she's looking pretty good
and then dating their sister
simultaneously
and having a child with a stripper and
we're supposed to just pretend this is
totally normal
well you know nope not allowed to
discuss it you know it's kind of weird
about it family was like
it's his sale it's his sister-in-law so
it's like
you know he's hooking up with his
sister-in-law i thought about how weird
it would be that they're like walking
around
in a relationship and they both have the
last name biden yeah and they're not
married
and their kids are first cousins but now
they're step brother and sister
so it's like so what do you what does
your dad know is like is it uncle
daddy you know exactly
you know i blame him i blame joe man and
i'm just i'm just imagining
like joe biden standing there with the
dog and the dog bites a guy
and then the dog's like got the guy's
arm and he's like help me joe and joe
looks at the dog and goes come on man
and dog just keeps going and it goes
back to during the transition period
when biden had that cast on and he said
oh he got out of the shower and he
pulled the dog's tail
which hey i've never pulled my dog's
tail that's just not something wait hold
hold on you know why is the dog in the
shower
well that's a little and why are you
playing with your dog naked also you
could say
but my point is these are the questions
that when
ivanka tweeted a photo of her
two-year-old making a lego house they
were like we demand to know if he did
this
on his own or did he have help and
you're like what's going on with the
the dog and the naked and the foot and
it's like no no no
and the sun like no not off limits joe
family is off limits
joe biden was in the shower with the dog
in the bathroom and he opens the shower
and tries to grab the dog's tail
you think it was a towel and yes oh god
and that's how he stores that's how he
sprained or broke his foot i think the
dog
and the no well i know maybe the dog
jumped on him
you know maybe the dog is trying to be
the alpha which is what i think probably
happened
or the dog just jumped out the middle of
the dog fell over because he's 78.
yeah big german shepherd but there's
something not being told
well i'm going to put it this way um i'm
imagining joe biden
oh i don't want to be imagining this
imagine i'm imagining from
outside the shower and i can't see
within the shower
joe biden is in there he has the door
open and the dog
walks in and is sitting there for some
reason and then hunter
in his i'm not hunter joe in his
senility
goes like he reaches and sees the tail
and thinks the tail's a towel starts
pulling on it
and the dog yanks him and he falls
forward and i'm kind of like
i mean it's a little benny hill but
maybe you know maybe
it's a weird story i'm thinking he
pulled the shower curtain open the dog
was like excited to see him and he maybe
even was like yeah come here and the dog
knocked him down
what exactly
separation anxiety no dogs in the
bathroom you know like
i i am i am sometimes a little bit even
prudish like dog
like bathroom time my time like my one
dog will try to knock on the door all
the time i'm like nope
outside like bathroom no matter what's
going on in the bathroom no one needs to
be privy to it
animal person i got i gotta ask um
maybe that was the first sign that dog
should have been taken away yeah when we
were like why is dog in the shower
like or outside the shower or whatever
is going on like what what you what are
you doing joe but now you see why
vladimir putin is challenging him to a
live conversation that has to be
streamed on youtube in real time
and it's like maybe this is why i mean
you know and i'm not mocking his
his senility because we all have family
members who have gone through and we
witnessed it i have a grandmother i have
a great aunt i've seen it before it's
it's heartbreaking and and it may happen
to me one day but i
i tweeted this actually a couple weeks
ago i like to think
the person i am married to loves me
enough at least that when i am
senile they will protect me from myself
and not parade me around for the world
to see
and what is happening to him right now
in real time we are witnessing
and no one loves him enough to say this
is this is not right and that's tragic
but listen it's everything we talked
about it's weakness it's people saying
i'm not going to get involved i'm not
going to stick my neck out it's the
security guard saying
i'm not going to help this woman it's
joe biden's own family
not telling him to sit down and shut up
joe you're too
old it's time to come home listen man
he's been in he was he served in
government what 47 years
i was saying this when he was running
it's like joe thank you for your service
i'm not a fan of joe bidenor's policies
but i get it we're going to be we're
going to be respectful and say
it's been a great 47 years you're 77
years old we got a nice little rocking
chair in the sun room for you get your
nice little blanket for your lap and you
can read some books
maybe play some candy crush or whatever
it is i don't know you probably need big
glasses because he's pretty old
yeah instead everyone around him is like
you should be the president
and now we're at the point where it's
the biden harris administration yeah
even and you know i wonder i i genuinely
wonder if joe doesn't understand what's
happening around him
i don't know i mean you look at that
summit recently in alaska
um now he wasn't present there but his
administration was and china just
basically laughed at us
on our own territory you look at these
these comments from vladimir putin
um you look at the the increasing
hostility from iran and you say the
world is not
the slightest bit concerned with with
him and so
the the collectivist world the u.n is
pushing
the paris accords the climate change
stuff heck we don't even have the
backbone to stand up and say let's not
have the olympics in china
because they have two million uyghur
slaves who they are beating and raping
on a daily basis
and we're like nah it's cool man make
another disney movie though to be fair
and with respect the bind administration
did issue sanctions on some chinese
officials from the xinjiang region
so i i can give you for that good
absolutely we give credit
yeah absolutely um i i hope it's the
right strategy you know i say it that
way because i'm like listen i'm glad
he's doing something
and i hope it's the right move it might
not work it might backfire it may work
perfectly
i'm glad the blind administration is at
least doing something and i wonder if
what was really going on is that china
was was this growing
you know a threat to the us to the world
for a lot of reasons
and we ignored it mostly because then
cell
right you want to run for office you're
going to talk about china you talk about
all these other issues
i you know i was we mentioned uh the
other day i was watching man of the year
with robin williams
there's the scene where he's complaining
he's like they're talking about an
amendment to the constitution to beg for
to ban flag burning while four million
illegal aliens cross our border that was
robin williams saying that mind you so
it's really interesting
but that's the point he's bringing up
when it comes to politics they're going
to come out and they're going to be like
oh look at all these problems we have
and then trump comes out and goes china
and he and he starts that narrative and
now all of a sudden people have started
to realize this
there have been polls showing that even
at a small percentage like a decent i
think it's like 30
of democrats are worried about china
mostly republicans
but not to the point where joe biden is
realizing the sentiment
and the focus on china has become too
much to ignore so now he kind of has no
choice
it's a remnant of the trump era policies
he has to maintain i'll never understand
when it comes to china and and
we've really gone off course from from
from crowder but it's fascinating how
this conversation evolves
i want to get rid of exactly i'll never
understand when it comes to china
being a kid of of the 80s i'm older than
you we just talked about ages earlier
we always treated the soviet union like
an enemy
we we were told the communist is a
communism and is it
an evil belief uh communists
don't want our our best intentions they
our enemy
we never moved our factories there right
but when it came to china we were like
communists are bad
but i mean you can make all of our dvd
players and our cars and now our wind
turbines and our solar panels and
basically everything that is sold on
amazon and 95 of our
yeah of our pharmaceutical industry and
and i'll never understand why we got
into bed with the communists because we
always knew communism was an evil belief
was it was that nixon
he opened up china to trade yeah yeah as
opposed to saying no they're no better
than the soviets
they look different but they are just as
evil because communism
is evil didn't we we treated cuba that
way we never said cuba's bad but you
know what
like why don't we move all of our like
sugar cane production there
but we did with china and it will always
remain fascinating to me and that is not
a partisan issue because
bush did it clinton did it another bush
did it
you know we all watched china rise but
we never had this
fear of china that we did with the
russians and people will say well the
fear of the russians was
overblown it was exaggerated but we were
we we were
we believed as a country that communism
was evil it is
and and and but not one of the chinese
like a weird neo-communist capitalist
amalgamation yeah we probably were using
the wrong word when we call them
communists we have authoritarians
defaulted to authoritarian
but like maybe there's a new
socio-political
movement or structure that could be
named and china has
enacted it i i don't want to offend our
our good
communist viewers by besmirching the
good name of course
it works locally absolutely by i'm just
kidding but all right
in the family communism and community
socialism in the
country capitalism i always put it like
this like
left libertarianism which is like
communism you know at its core ideology
only works when it's like a handful of
people living a farm together yeah it's
like you know i i picked up the eggs
from the chickens
would you like to share like commune
exactly
yeah it doesn't scale up because you
know that was the joke you made the
other night
this is the question i was actually
wondering when you mentioned like we
said russia the soviet union was bad
china is bad but we can still trade with
them who killed more people didn't i
didn't mao kill like substantially more
people close to 100 million
yeah that's what i thought like starting
almost double people don't even know
yeah yeah
isn't like double what stalin what the
soviet union did yeah
let's work with them exactly exactly
yeah i mean he
he starved close to 100 million of his
own of his own people
pig iron um you know about the pig iron
stuff no never heard of that i don't
know the full story but it was like he
he ordered everybody to melt down their
tools or whatever
oh yeah what was that about like they
were trying to make weapons i guess they
were
they were judge and build their
infrastructure yeah and then no one had
anything with which to cook
or to farm or to same with the sparrows
that's right i was gonna say the great
sparrow campaign because the sparrows
were eating the wheat
and that was the biggest predator of
wheat so they were like great kill all
the sparrows and you'd get a little
badge
every time you killed a sparrow and all
the kids were taught to kill sparrows to
get
badges until the locusts came and they
looked
no sparrows to eat them because there
were no sparrows to eat them and then
you know something absurd like 13
million people died that year
because there was no wheat because the
locusts destroyed all the wheat crops
and you say well this is why communists
should not be ever in control well but
hold on can't you eat the locusts
i imagine you could mill them into a
paste and you know make bread with them
or something
but they come from above i will not eat
the bugs i will not live in the pods
that's right yeah i'm not gonna eat yeah
all my eating bugs i got no problem with
eating bugs man that's
yeah other ones you can catch i watch
these videos where it's like some dude
at the middle of nowhere and he's like
all super ripped and he's like
if you want to survive in the wild you
gotta figure out where to find water and
then he goes and like drinks muddy water
and then he's like and food and he lifts
a rock and he's like eating milk i'm
kidding
i'm half kidding but there's a lot of
these videos of like survival and
dysentery
here here are the bugs you can eat
here's how you eat them you say cook
them and i'm like
i don't care about eating bugs when
there's no other food i will i mean
whatever yeah
same you know what you do you said
listen listen you do it you need to do
this
we got chickens i brought it up earlier
but we have chickens they walk around
all day all they do is eat bugs yeah
and then when they're old enough they
poop out an egg yes you know and you eat
the egg
i don't got to eat the bugs i eat the
egg there you go problem solved were we
talking about china
transmutation matter yeah yeah having
all the locusts
and uh the problem ultimately was the
command economy yes
that's that you know it's the idea of
communism
is this utopian idea that everyone's
holding hands and everyone owns
everything and the factory just operates
and there's no hierarchy no leadership
and it's it's usually you know like
children and
and uh the ignorant who propose it
because they don't realize
what specialties are yeah so like you
have someone whose specialty is
building a keystone pipeline as a welder
with 25 years experience and then you're
told by
quasi communist john kerry well you can
just build a solar panel now
exactly so what happens is when somebody
who actually
knows how the infrastructure of
pipelines work
is seeing all of his specialists who
build pipelines
and they're told by the guy in
government make solar panels
he's like we don't know how to do that
think about how that scales up in
communism
the communist government says just have
them all make solar panels and they go
here here and they bang the gavel
and then all of a sudden a bunch of
people are like looking down at
circuitry and photovoltaic cells and
they're like
what what do i what do i do i plug what
in the what and where and like
that's what now did with the farmers
right he took a bunch of like professors
and intelligentsia and moved them out to
the farms and it was like now you farm
and they were like we don't know how and
then they all starved yeah yeah
in the soviet union they used to
determine output by weight so they would
say how
how many nails did you produce well we
measure output by weight
so they made really fat heavy nails and
and which are useless
right yeah they're not any good but they
were they were they were hitting the
criteria and that is the collectivist
concern i have of this administration
when it comes to tomorrow they're going
to unveil a four trillion dollar
infrastructure and jobs plan
and who's going to four trillion dollars
how long is the over how many
months or years does that come in oh i'm
uh you know i wow
another four trillion we'll see it come
out tomorrow but who are these
collectivists saying
yes this is what we need to make happen
this is democratic
i have willed a train we were talking
about this earlier from miami to seattle
is on the map
and they showed you the map of going
through florida and all across
the the panhandle the high-speed rail
with the high-speed rail now how much
land they're going to have to confiscate
will be absolutely fascinating
but who is this person that has decided
is there really that much of a move
from people from miami to well probably
from seattle to miami because everyone's
going to florida
california's been trying for 10 years
now to build this high-speed rail
they are a hundred billion dollars at
price point it's not even close to done
it's 12 years behind schedule
and the price point is so expensive that
no one will be able to afford to take
the train well this is what happens when
collectivists decide they want to be in
charge of the train system
right vanderbilt never had this problem
and he built more darn trains in this
country than anyone in the world
and somehow he made it work take a look
at what china's doing
they've somehow managed to use the
authoritarian system to control
capitalistic infrastructure allowing
them to rapidly expand their
infrastructure they have what 40 000
kilometers of high-speed rail yeah we
can't even get this one done in
california yeah
you know why because there's no
environmental group suing to say what
about the spotted turtle
there is no labor group saying you
cannot do this we need to have uh
weekends off there's no child protection
group there's no osha
so you can get a lot done and that's
what drives me crazy when authoritarians
like paul krugman
and other economists say they marvel at
what china is able to do
this is incredible they built this whole
olympic stadium for beijing in a week
it's like well yes they were able to do
that when you have basically slave labor
with no opposition with no freedoms you
can build the birds nest in beijing in
record time
yeah it's it's amazing what you can do
as a country when you
weld people into their homes when they
get sick and you kidnap them overnight
for insulting their police
and and the the authoritarians like john
kerry and paul krugman are never the
ones
who will be conscripted to the labor and
that's why when people were like bernie
sanders is a communist i would always
say he's not a communist
he is a communist party leader because
at the height of the soviet union's
misery there was never a shortage of
vodka or caviar
and that is what john kerry and paul
krugman and all these folks are they are
never the working-class
nine-year-old girl who was forced in the
labor mines
they are the party leaders that show up
in big fancy cars and have a toast
remember when maduro ate the empanada on
tv remember that
in venezuela his nation is starving oh
yeah
yeah and he's still very plump and while
he's talking
he just reaches into a drawer in his
desk and pulls out an empanada
and takes a bite of it and now i'm just
like dude you couldn't wait 10 minutes
he had to eat an empanada while his
nation's starving yeah
absolutely insane when i was in
venezuela you know what i saw
how a command economy functions very
similarly to what you're saying about
china
in order to make jobs they just say make
it a job
so i went to go buy a cell phone and
there was like six different desks you
had to go to
i walked and talked to one guy it's the
acquisitions department tom what i'm
looking for and he explains to me sends
me over to the
the supply desk i need to go to each
individual person you want to pick out
your plan
you got to go to the person who who
helps you pick out the plan then you
gotta go to the person who actually goes
and gets the card for you
then you gotta go to the person who
helps you pick out a phone then you
gotta go to the person who actually gets
the phone
they made fake jobs for the sake of
having jobs whereas in the us
you walk into the phone store this
person walks up to you say i'd like a
phone no problem they pull it up they
punch in the number
take your card swipe it you're good to
go for the sake of having jobs
they just make everything worse oh
that's because a private company in the
united states
wants to cut down an overhead so they
don't hire superfluously but
the the government can just accrue tax
dollars to pay for
nonsense and then they work for me now
but it's it's not just about tax dollars
because it's it's you know communism or
whatever they're just basically like
we want everyone to be working you know
idols
playground or whatever so make them work
make jobs
and so i'm like why did it take me three
hours to buy this phone wow and a phone
barely worked yeah i went to the mall
the mall was dead it's like all the
stores are closed well
they can't just mandate you can mandate
a job for a company that's a necessity
people need cell phones
this technology is important for people
to work and for the economy to grow so
that that was in spite of what the
government was doing
at a mall where small businesses are
supposed to flourish and experiment and
make products
they couldn't they couldn't do it
because people didn't have the resources
now the craziest thing
these photos from venezuela of the
bolivar i think it's the boulevard
fuerte now
their currency because the boulevard the
billion dollar bills
yeah they had the bolivar first then
they were like we're going to change
this to the boulevard fuerte
and then they launched that and now
those videos are just people shoveling
into the trash
yeah it's like garbage bags full of
money and p it's like
more useful as toilet paper than
anything else that's devastating
venezuela will always fascinate me i
always have to talk about energy it's
what i do for a living but
they are the country with the world's
largest oil reserves proven oil reserves
venezuela
um they went from one of the world
leaders in oil to
now there's roughly a week wait to fill
up your car with gas
and you say how milton friedman used to
joke that if the federal government were
in charge of of the sahara desert they'd
eventually run out of sand
right it was his favorite joke and and
this this is the country with the
largest oil reserves
cannot produce oil anymore it seems as
though it's intentional
by the cia because they don't want to
use opec dollars they've been
staunchly anti-military industrial
complex and like yeah we're going to
destroy your economy
suffer maybe yeah they're one of the
targets but sure but venezuela
can and then they mine can can pull the
oil out of the ground it's like they
don't have the technology they've been
sanctioned they couldn't get like well i
heard they couldn't get toilet paper i
was never there
um and then they made a villain out of
their leader like it's it's who makes it
where does that come from uh cia the cia
makes a toilet paper
no they just sank the us government
sanctioned venezuela so venezuela needs
to
if they were a capitalist economy hey
they do a really really they joined us
if they simply joined the military
i'm not saying that i'm saying if
venezuela allowed small businesses to
grow and flourish
and they didn't mandate ridiculous
garbage jobs maybe they'd have their own
toilet paper and wouldn't be worried
about the sanctions
maybe they would then have the
infrastructure and the capability of
producing machines that could
harvest the oil and the petroleum and
refine it but there's kind of a small
country and they're a jungle country too
so they don't have a lot of the
resources that like a jungle country
yeah there's a lot of jungle and then so
they need to develop it the problem is
they're a mismanaged command economy
where an overweight man eats an empanada
on tv while his nation is starving and
the cia wants them gone
i i don't look man oh yeah if if my
neighbor was mad at me and he was
blocking the road
to like to my house or whatever and
there were still like tons of land on my
property and the capability of taking
care of myself
there's a certain point where you got to
be like well i shouldn't have bought a
property with no you know with no
easement for the road
venezuela has the ability the problem is
they are a horribly mismanaged
country maduro was a bus driver hugo
chavez was like
we want a working person to be in charge
so this bus driver is going to be the
president from now on we're going to pop
it away
didn't venezuela dissolve their congress
or something i mean
venezuela before hugo chavez came into
power was by far the wealthiest country
in latin america and by far the most
educated i mean they were almost on par
with the united states in terms of gdp
in terms of prosperity um so to watch
their decline
under someone who was elected under a
lot of the same rhetoric we hear
fair share the rich get richer the poor
get poorer um when i'm in charge we're
going to have a blah blah blah and
people
going back to the one of the earlier
conversations people vote for their own
interests and if you make their interest
taking other people's prosperity wealth
uh absolving your debt people are going
to vote for that oh it's possible
because bush and that's what happened
bush hated chavez yeah junior and and
just because he
used military industrial complex all the
way they wanted venezuela's oil so maybe
maduro was kind of like a cia plant they
got him in and now they're villainizing
him
to make that they let him ruin the
country now now they're like we got to
get him out and put another guy in
that's even more sympathetic to him this
is all conspiracy level stuff
yeah but it's all we talk about the cia
and their involvement
and we just we're never going to know we
understand that's the
the tales of economic hitmen but
the fact of the matter remains i have
been to venezuela
i've literally seen how awfully managed
the country is
i have seen other journalists go there
and go to potemkin supermarkets and lie
about the food they have luke went there
he went to a random neighborhood market
he's like it's empty he traveled around
and saw how bad it was
and his other journalists come out with
these videos where they're like look at
all this glorious food in venezuela and
it's like
clearly that's not true i had to flee
the country rather quickly because i got
accused of being a spy simply for being
there and showing people what was really
going on
there were protests students were
revolting it was bad
caracas at the time was the murder
capital of the world
this is a problem of leadership and i
get it
maybe there's the cia doing everything
their power to stop them but listen
if they're a jungle nation maybe they
should start developing parts of their
country
it used to be that people would go out
with a saw and just chop trees down and
develop land
then we got machinery maybe they can't
get access to a lot of these things but
it doesn't explain why they have
ridiculous jobs or ridiculous companies
why they can't start small businesses
where they can't produce food and they
have all of this oil
they don't know how to use properly now
apparently oil is cheap for the people
there
but it's really hard to get because
they're horribly mismanaged well when
you're shoveling your
your currency into the fireplace it
doesn't matter if it's cheap right right
i mean if it costs 45 cents a gallon you
say well that's cheap
but but if hyperinflation makes your
currency useless well then 45 cents is
is as expensive as four dollars and also
hyperinflation is
is obviously their fault it's it is the
fault of
their own country they're reacting so if
i'm not gonna call it reacting it's it's
mismanagement bro so communists don't
you could it doesn't work
now i'll tell you this china's certainly
figured it out but look at what china
does
with their capitalistic enterprises
venezuela doesn't do that
they have a command economy maybe they'd
learn if they just looked at what china
was doing and they could make their
pseudo-communism work but i guess that
wouldn't really be they're
so tiny that's their problem they're
kind of a satellite state
i feel like it's not an excuse for our
country to be like but but america is
mean to us
it's like so you have to
like you're responsible for yourself man
you can't complain that someone else
won't send you toilet paper i'm coming
i'm curious to see what happens with
china as their crackdown on hong kong
continues because it is a huge
economic engine it's a world economic
engine a financial hub
um they're and they're they're really
cracking down hard on hong kong
and if if hong kong is unable to compete
on on a financial world
level in freedom i wonder what that does
the overall chinese economy i mean like
like taking over hong kong hard has been
a 20-year plan
since the turnover which i think was
like january 1st 2000 right wasn't it
right at the beginning of the
millennial was when when the millennia
when when the uk gave up hong kong i
don't remember the exact date
there was like a certain time frame
there was a certain time frame and and
here we are 20 years later and basically
that even
i'm sure the buy administration would
recognize the word on the street is for
the expats is
don't stay in hong kong it's kind of
crazy hong kong
was a british colony and then they were
like after 100 years i think it was
we're going to give it back to china
china's like we're going to take hong
kong but we're not going to infringe on
some of their sovereignty
although they did by extraditing
criminals to the chinese courts because
that's like
but hong kong's never supposed to be
independent that was never part of the
deal so this whole like free hong kong
thing is not what was ever part of the
global plan
the u.s is pushing it right now because
everyone i think a lot of americans
would love to see a
independent hong kong state but the idea
was the british give it to the chinese
terrifying as it is that was the plan
are we gonna what are we gonna back out
on that um what year do we live in
2021's where thank you thank you where
a country the uk can be like we're going
to give
the people of this you know a small
island still a colonization plan or
pennsylvania they still have
australia and canada britain that's
crazy but what i'm saying is like
if what would happen right now if the uk
was like we're going to give america to
canada
we'd be like shut your mouth that's just
not happening
and so what really happens is china
sends in
spies and propagandists and military and
they
conquered hong kong they did they
install their people
they remove anyone who opposes them and
now they're just eroding away at the
institutions and hong kong will be taken
over at the administrative level
it's freakish and i can't see i mean i
feel
justice at the core of my soul and i
feel like justice is to deliver hong
kong to the chinese as was planned
how was it because that was part of the
contract the people of hong kong didn't
agree to that contract no people 100
years ago agreed to it see how well
they're all
gone it's crazy system i mean what do we
break the contract i don't think we have
to stick to the contract
you know they did the balfour
declaration
uh i think it was post-world war one was
like hey arabs since you betrayed the
ottomans and helped us win world war one
the british and the french were like
we're gonna we're gonna give you the
land of where now israel is and then at
the end of world war one they
they reneged on that contract and said
no arabs we're not going to give it to
you
they created the israeli state and
that's where all this tension came from
the arabs like we were supposed to have
that it was a contract
yeah i i think giving people their
freedom is always a good thing but
returning people to an evil regime is
not and so to say
like we're going to give hong kong its
independence from from the crown
i mean we got our independence from the
crown i would be in favor of that but
that would be like america saying and
now we're going to give puerto rico to
cuba
yeah and right it's like well because
you speak the same language and you're
very close to each other like well wait
a second why why are you sacrificing
us as your people and i feel like the
british had they were their people and
they turned them over
and they turned them over to the
communists and i mean we fought the
whole eastern bloc of
europe was to prevent the the uh soviet
union from incringing
infringing more and more in there you
know because we realized how evil it was
and now it's like ah you can just take
it as well you know
take the czech republic it's all good
you got take austria you guys speak the
same language anyway
isn't it really funny that two world
wars in a cold war were fought for the
express purpose of stopping
one consolidation consolidated power
taking over europe
and then finally they're just like maybe
we should just do it anyway
and then the european union comes in and
there you go yeah yeah
exactly and now we're teaching all our
kids mandarin in class because we think
it's fun it's like great we'll just
just learn learn the language of your
your your conquering overlords
hey you know get ready for assimilation
hong kong is the elephant
in on er is in the room right now like
what do we do
if it becomes independent china will
invade and we'll be forced to have some
defensive pact
catalyzing world war one all over again
or whatever some stupid
if we if we if the british keep it then
they're under violation of contract i
mean that's that'd be a terrible
situation china would take it even if
britain was like we're keeping it they'd
like that
they would don't care it's i mean it's
basically connected to china
they're going to take taiwan because to
the pro-chinese individuals
they genuinely think taiwan is already
part of china
the one china policy so they're like
other youtubers who are super pro-china
who have like ragged on me and they're
like taiwan is not an independent nation
it is not recognized as one it is a part
of china
and i'm like okay well you know you have
no control over them so i i
i beg to differ you're gonna need to
send in military
to conquer that island because you don't
have control over them they are
independent yeah
this is and that's completely different
than the hong kong taiwan is like
another
point is china is preparing to go in
and take taiwan so you think the the uk
saw the writing on the wall and they
were like
well we've fallen from from grace as one
of the great empires of the world and
now we're a tiny island nation that
can't even win over it when a deal with
the eu for
it takes three or four years what are
they going to do against china
the queen is powerless so she dropped to
her knees and she kissed the pinky ring
of xi jinping
that's what the queen did pathetic and
that's why we should
impeach the queen absolutely impeach
queen elizabeth she's a bigot
do this this song the olympics in china
it's so world war reminiscent of world
war ii like we're gonna seed land to
them like we did with czechoslovakia i
think it was and then
we're gonna hold the olympics in china
to appease them show the world they're
not so bad yeah exactly
then joe biden's gonna go come on man
peace in our time
and for reference then we hosted the
olympics in nazi germany yeah
what was the 1930s and our u.s olympic
committee just allowed today they passed
a
a ruling that you are allowed to protest
the national anthem
at the upcoming olympics so we will have
quasi-communist athletes in china
kneeling at the national anthem
after their taxpayers just paid for
their like four years as well i'm sorry
speed skater or whatever their little
activity is why are people ragging on me
for being so pessimistic
we've got a diversity chief at the
pentagon who's now being
he's being canceled for offensive tweets
we have these diversity inclusivity and
equity officers at all of our companies
and schools
our military is purging people who
believe in the in the vision of the
founding fathers
sorry man we are turning into a
satellite state of china
if i were you people should be most
afraid of china is not the eu
or or the uk because of their
relationship with hong kong
um if i were in south korea i would be
the most afraid
because they are still a free and
independent and autonomous and
capitalist country
and thriving and prosperous um but they
are small
and now they have 30 000 americans who
are standing at the dmz as if north
korea is going to invade which is all a
joke
but the other side of north korea is
communist china and if i was in south
korea
and and maybe there are some of you i'm
sure there are some of them listening
i'd love to know their thoughts if there
are
you know what do you think of this
rising chinese state because we're still
pretty far from china
and they're growing their navy but
there's still an ocean away they don't
have an air force per se they do have
nuclear warheads
but but north korea is within a march i
think that would scare me
we spend too much time focusing on
things like nukes china has been
developing
powerful uh cyber cyber warfare
capabilities
they've been attacking our
infrastructure i would not be surprised
if china has infected the u.s uh
u.s industry silicon valley at every
single level it's so easy man yeah
you know it's almost like they could
unleash a virus on the world yeah
and yeah like they have a computer virus
all these
infrastructure systems we have a
computer virus so what they do is
hackers it's an age-old trick that will
always work because humans are
predictable
i remember back in the day a guy would
have a floppy disk you know the old a
drive floppy disk five and a half one
point
four four megabytes still the same
there was a three and a half and then
there's the five and a quarter the three
and a half for the 1.44 megabytes and
they put a virus on it and they would
drop it in front of a bank
and they'd walk away you know what
happens a bank employee sees a floppy
disk and goes i wonder what this is
sticks it in their computer don't affect
the whole system nice then
cds came out you know the hacker started
doing dropping a cd in front of a bank
then usb sticks came out you know what
the hacker started doing dropping a usb
stick in front of a bank
what this is yup so you find a google
employee and
someone from someone who supports for
china or
you know operating for china's best
because easily it's it's so much easier
than this
they could literally apply for a job a
member of the chinese communist party
could move to the us become a citizen
slip through the cracks
go to school university plug in the usb
into their hard drive and
own their entire network it's almost
like one could be senator dianne
feinstein's driver for 20 straight years
and no one even knows about it
that was real right chinese spy yeah 20
years as a driver
and no one questioned wow he was a
driver for 20 years like it's pretty
i was i my first job in the senate was a
driver but that's the job of like a
kid it pays nothing and it's a driver
and you eventually kind of work your way
up
but this guy was like nope i just want
to be her driver listening to all of her
phone
calls or you could be a
um democrat running for office being
supported by your good friend
fung fung yes he's been in china
in in more ways than one and and he
knows
what's happening around the pulse there
yeah well look man
i i try to be optimistic as much as i
can but uh there's a lot of things to be
optimistic is
chickens chickens technology technology
human spirit
star star base city elon musk's new city
wants to build and europe
million fans who are watching right now
who believe in freedom and the human
spirit and
prosperity that's true and there are a
lot of us out there um it's
but you're right it is easy to be be
defeatist um yeah without a doubt
yeah but you know what every every day
we get up we do this show and talk about
the stuff it's because we're not giving
up yeah like if we were playing
minecraft videos if we were playing civ
right if this was a global game of
civilization i would not be trying to
militarily defeat china i would be
looking for other
other ways cultural victory scientific
victory let's build a spaceship first
elon musk has gone for that spaceship we
can colonize mars before the chinese
colonized mars that's a big
jump start on control of our solar
system
if if that's such a desired plan yeah
elon musk is building starship
that they had a failure again on the
fourth test which is sad but you know
he'll keep working
and one of the victories in civilization
the video game is to colonize space
before anyone else
so uh if elon musk gets that done i
don't see china working on you know
colonizing space they're well behind us
in that regard yeah
so maybe we'll be on mars and then china
will be like yeah well we got the
biggest economy
and then a bunch of americans on mars
will be laughing and cracking open
champagne and being like look at all
this red rock we got
you got nothing it's iron baby it's iron
all right let's jump over to super chats
if you have not already my good friends
please do us the honor of smashing that
like button because it really does help
don't forget to subscribe we are so
close to breaking one
million subscribers there are 41 000
people watching this right now if
everybody who wasn't subscribed
subscribed
i'm pretty sure we would break a million
so please consider subscribing
and also share the show if you really
like it don't forget to go to
timcast.com become a member my friends
i believe we're going to give another
projection the new site will be up this
week at some point we thought it was
going to be last week but
we want to make sure that when the
rollout happens nobody's adversely
effective because you know there's bugs
and stuff so
we're working on it but this new site is
gonna have a bunch of awesome content
we're gonna bring on some writers we're
gonna actually produce articles and
cultural commentary so it won't just be
podcasts
it's going to be a lot more than that
that being said it is time to go to
those
super chats so as always youtube for
some reason blocks the name of the first
super chit so i apologize they say
our country is effed what skills should
i pick up to survive in this dystopian
world
okay you should download
a general survival guide app to your
phone right now
not because the world is going to end
but because sometimes people get lost in
the woods
imagine that you're lost in the woods
you're like what do i do and you pull it
up
if you're lost in the woods do this boom
you get saved you know what a lot of
people do they make a mistake of
their car breaks down the middle of
nowhere they leave their car yeah really
easy to spot a car from the sky
really hard to spot a person that's a
big mistake see
survival apps you got to do
all right let's see tony pieces i love
how the nra is posting ads on your
channel everyone just remember no other
group has done more for gun control than
the nra
is that true i don't know i'm not a big
fan of vienna i'm not a huge fan
i'm a fan of gun rights but there's a
lot of other smaller organizations that
i feel do
way more i was really i wasn't you know
i've only in the past year or so been
getting more and more into guns and
stuff but when that philando castile
thing happened i got really mad at the
nra
you know that story legal gun owner
black man in his car
with a legal gun and the cop pull you
know just he gets pulled over and the
cop
is talking to him and he says i got my
firearm with me the cop panics and
shoots him
oh and where was the nra they dragged
their feet well we got to get all the
details i'm like nah dude a legal gun
owner was shot by a cop who was legally
holding his gun
that's messed up dude not a fan of that
stuff
but i don't know i i don't i guess i
don't know enough about the nra to say
you know
anything all right let's see tony rogers
says tim you should have crowder on your
show i dare ya
i would love to have steven crowder on
this show
but crowder runs his own company and so
i will tell you this
i have spoken with crowder and i've said
bro
open invitation whenever just come on
the show he's in texas
he's got his own employees his own
business this is the difficulty with
having people on the show who do other
shows
i know a lot of people are like get
skype get skype we're not set up for it
i honestly don't want to be set up for
it there is a much better dynamic when
you're sitting in a room with someone
looking them in the eyes and having that
conversation
so i'll be honest too we've had a lot of
people
who have hit me up high profile
prominent personalities who are like i
wanna come on your show
via zoom or skype and i'm like i'll be
honest first
i did install zoom on this when we were
first getting set up
and it somehow like broke obs
and i had to do a uh one of those um
previous state thing what was it called
rewind did i had to rewind the computer
yeah i know what you mean because i
don't know what caused it
we even we even had a recent guest who
was like i'm going to use the browser
version of zoom and that
also disrupted and i was like oh geez
that's causing us problems
so i was like you know what man it just
remote doesn't work the same way
it really really doesn't but uh you know
i'd love to have crowder on
michael uh konani uh konani says
have crowder on the irl yes
well what you guys need to do is you
need to tweet at stephen and say go fly
out to you know tim's place and
mr stephen fly out of tim's come on his
show because we'd love to have him
titus flavius says just felt the need to
correct your fallout lore from yesterday
bottle caps are not a fiat currency they
are backed by clean drink cleaning
drinking water for their value
clean drinking water needs some some uh
documentation on that
statement you know you can melt them
down into bullets maybe
it's crazy jtw geek says tim did you
know the book of revelations
was written written in code it's
revelation someone someone yelled at me
for saying
no yes it's revelation john the baptist
was a prisoner
and couldn't send religious texts to his
followers so we had to make it sound
like a madman's ravings
interesting i love this austin d says
tim and the gang love the show so when
are you bringing on crowder literally
right now
crowder could show up at two in the
morning i would go live with him if he
was here
that'd be fun i'd have to drive down be
fun you should bring crowder on
oh that's a good idea and also steve
krause
you can get them good ideas it's more up
to uh to crowder than it is to me
because of course he's welcome to come
on the show
there's a lot of people who want to have
on the show but you know some people are
big popular famous with their own
platforms they don't need or want to
come on the show so
rising underdog says tim fly stephen
crowder out and and have him on your
show this week
also you and adam crowley need to be in
each other's shows
neat i i something tells me that stephen
crowder is substantially wealthier than
i am and doesn't need me to fly him out
but i would absolutely fly him out
first class put him up in a five-star
hotel all that stuff
because i like stephen crowder i think
he's great and i'd love to have him on
the show
but uh look i can especially imagine
right now with everything that's going
on he's gonna be 10 times busier than
usual
and this is his business they're putting
under threat but it'll be great to have
him absolutely
sean reynolds says tim you and steven
and tom mcdonald are single-handedly
changing the next generation
my 14-year-old brother-in-law listens to
you stephen and ben shapiro all the time
i hope to get you to meet you someday
keep it up brother i appreciate it
that's awesome i i heard recently from a
friend that there are some 13 and 14
year olds who watch the show
and i'm like i'm glad we're family
friendly then and i'm
i and i actually think you see we need
to uh
inspire kids to do things to be
responsible to be strong to grow up
and i'm also willing to believe that a
lot of parents wouldn't let their kids
watch a show if we were cussing non-stop
and if we were saying really lewd and
lascivious things so um
it's probably a good thing that we're
family friendly because it's not just
about whether a kid wants to watch show
it's about like you know when i was a
little kid my dad would turn on the next
star trek the next generation
and i don't know i just had there and
watched it but i grew up with that show
it's an all-time favorite show i watch
it still like every single day reruns
over and over again brilliant
and that's the power of some kid sitting
with his dad and his dad being like this
show
is fine for my kid to listen to it's
important ideas if we were cussing up a
storm
they'd be like i'll watch this later you
would still get
a few like i had mother and daughter
would watch my youtube videos but i was
pretty profane but
not i could it's hard to measure like if
i hadn't been swearing i
probably would have been a lot more of
them i would guess i don't know
yeah that's rockstar when you get
multiple generations of family
that's awesome justin bookman says hey
ian is a fellow ohioan
have uh did you ever go to kings island
or i
don't know how do you pronounce this
giaga lake oh geogra-lake giaga
yeah in aurora ohio that was my go-to
that was my first theme park
i went on the big dipper and the
corkscrew eventually
uh awesome the double loop knows the
double loop i did go on the big dipper
that was a
and uh cedar point it never went to
kings island though all right he also
says i have some i also have some book
recommendations battlefield earth by l
ron hubbard
great movie i mean kind of a terrible
movie but great movie
sphere and prey by michael crichton
oh creighton crichton street lawyer and
the testament by john grisham
hi lids hello i hear your sphere is
really epic did you ever read that no
michael crichton novel yeah it's
supposed to be super great they go
underwater or something liam dean says
discovered crowder back in 2016 when it
was just him and
not gay jared he introduced me to
shapiro sargon even you tim
thanks to you all uh thanks to you all
i've been able to stay sane in a world
full of jiggly puffs
much obliged all it is truly a world
full of jigglypuffs
oh what a good memory thank you
get this hate speech off our campus yeah
max sullivan has been watching your show
for a couple of months subscribe to your
page after seeing lieutenant colonel
west on your show
always great content thought-provoking
intelligent discussions thanks
well thank you very much for those super
chats
all right let's see paul
sikora says this nonsense with crowder
is ridiculous bill richmond drinks their
milkshake
here's money to plug mug club again
release the half asian kraken yes
if you guys want to look i can shout out
my website but for now
the important thing is to make sure that
crowder is able to keep doing what he
does
and that's louder with crowder.com and
then join their mug club
because they're look again they might
not want to hear it but it really does
seem like they're coming for
crowder and this time it seems to make
it's unjustifiable it's illegitimate
i disagree with a lot of the rules
anyway because i had a question earlier
at what point
do community guidelines become editorial
standards
almost immediately well hold on if
youtube's like
you can't harass other people on this
platform
define harassment well you know when you
see it i'm like okay that's kind of
vague
when they say you can't talk about this
you can't have an opinion on this
you can't present data on this okay well
hold on there
these are editorial guidelines for
people at
you know who are posting to youtube it's
a publisher but
not not that that really matters it
doesn't change the 230 distinction
but at a certain point there's questions
that need to be raised about whether or
not they're news publications
who just are bypassing i guess
regulation by claiming
that people who are posting to youtube
are free to do whatever they want
because we saw uber already got
you know that that i can't remember i
think it was somewhere in europe
uber uber drivers are now employees or
something youtube is treading
dangerously close to this territory
by telling me what opinions i can or
can't have
what names i can or can't say it is not
a community guideline to tell me i can't
say a name
but they've done that no that's an
editorial stance because i've worked for
news companies and the editor is like
don't do these stories because we've got
issues with that okay well is youtube an
open platform for posting videos
then i should be able to have whatever
opinion i want if i target people
or even groups of people that i get if
they're like hey you can't disparage a
group of people
okay i understand that but what about my
political opinion on say an election
nope nope nope those are banned now
that's getting creepy
all right we got uh samuel pyle says my
generation zoomers are going to do a tax
strike and we need at least 10 million
people to show the government we
patriots won't be ignored
i don't know uh how how you pull off
something like that to be really honest
i've always wondered um when i like
people need to stand up and and and just
if every individual said you know i
refuse to work as a waiter unless i get
paid this wage
and then you get paid that wage the
problem is people are all willing to
work for a company for a trash wage and
then just complain about it
all right daniel o'sullivan says on
crowder's last vid on the show vin
chauvin trial he pulls up a message
received from twitter regarding his
suspension
but the overlaid is blurred cahoots i
don't know much about that i do know
he's also
suspended from twitter because they said
he made offensive comments or something
i have no idea
brent smith said tim would like to teach
you and your crew how to scuba dive if
you have any interest
think would be a great episode can put
together safety divers for movie if ever
needed
scott's scuba service we will travel hey
thanks man appreciate that sounds pretty
cool
i love it all right let's see we'll grab
some more subjects here
it's just a a period and they say why do
the republicans think they're going to
win they keep ignoring and discarding
their voters why would anyone support
them
you're here that's exactly your hair's
thinking here yep
i really don't expect to vote republican
ever again and a lot of people are like
tim that's defeated you have to work
republican no i don't
i voted for trump because trump was
something different and there were a few
things i liked that he was doing
i do not like the republican party at
all none of them
no i i do a lot of fox and and the last
time
uh fox tv show and i'm usually the token
republican and i usually take umbrage
i mean i love doing it but i am i
republican uh
holy cow i don't think so i mean am i on
the right absolutely
but i don't want to know what
republicans are on the right these days
there didn't seem to be a whole heck of
a lot
if i lived in where's rand paul kentucky
kentucky if i lived in kentucky
absolutely
i'd vote for rand paul uh i don't and
i'm not
maybe i mean i guess the idea is i don't
want democrats in congress because that
what they do as a collective is
different from what they do as
individuals you know you could have an
individual
you know saying like we're going to be a
moderate and we're going to do all these
nice things for you but no you're not
you're going to get on your knees
whoever the speaker of the house is so
i'm not interested in that yeah
problem is voting against is a dangerous
game because if you don't know what
you're voting for
and you vote against something you might
end up voting something worse than
exactly
yeah exactly well i don't know what you
do about it
start your own party i mean really
honestly what it comes down to is you do
it yourself
that's i'll just write it in crossland
right now and then we'll make a it'll be
it'll be a funny uh um t-shirt no no
it'll just be like a very funny
circumstance where ian one day wakes up
and everyone just wrote his name in and
he finds himself as president and he
doesn't know what's going on
i almost wrote my name in 2016. i was so
flustered with that experience
all right pepperos says many of us in
the military look at this as a joke
we know this is not training this is
brainwashing tactics that many college
lefties say we go through
this time i agree they can shove it we
see through their bs
i think that person raises a great point
in that i'm sure a lot of people
are just like i have to sit through this
class for an hour all right i'll sit
through the class and what do you want
me to say at the end say this
okay fine i'll sit through it it still
shouldn't be happening but i wouldn't be
surprised if that's the predominant
response of just like let me just get
through this easy credits
yeah you know like yeah like when you're
in college professor what do you want me
to say uh okay sure i'll say this
because you don't have to show up give
me a name yeah i am
all right so the civic nationalist says
tim earlier today you said that very few
people stand up for people nowadays
but that is how it's always been there
are those who are adventurers and those
who learn about those discoveries
be the change you want to see that's a
very good point
frank says make the voting test be the
same as the immigration test
i mean that's actually a really good
point you know and then we can frame it
as though like well you support
immigrants don't you yeah there was a
statistic not recently uh maybe
like two weeks ago that was 60 of
americans couldn't pass
the the civics the the uh the
citizenship exam
and it's not exactly a hard exam and
most
couldn't possibly pass it we've got a
timothy peterson says
crt critical race theory in the military
on my first day of basic drill sergeant
clark said
quote there are no insert every slur you
can think of in this platoon
we are all green if you don't work
together you will fail
that's not critical race theory that
actually like
that's in my opinion a great statement
don't be racist
learn to work together critical race
theory would be like them coming in
and then saying like there are no of
this
you know racial slur but there are some
of this racial slur
and they need to recognize why they're a
problem for this platoon
and you should go do push-ups that's
what critical race theory is
all right we got shoddy vice versus i
find it funny that people say solar
energy is super good
i started working in the field and holy
moly there's a lot of circuitry and
issues with the inverters
i i love this guy yes absolutely
amen explain it elaborate well i mean
look the technology is not there yet and
so we are forcing it
we talked a lot about collectivism and
central government we are forcing it
faster than the technology allows
solar panels on your house can maybe
power your house
if you're not running the washer i'm
sorry the dryer in the microwave
simultaneously
right but it cannot there is no country
that is running its electricity on 100
renewable
and there are countries that are way
greener than america wants to be
and it does not happen yet nobody refers
that there are no advanced
countries isn't like denmark doing like
100 wind
no god no not even close no no and and
they may be claiming they are
but they all have fossil fuel
redundancies
right there is no there is no 100
renewable and so
and where are they all made well 75
percent of them china
now there you go so we'll keep buying
solar panels from china this is a very
important point from
k lorraine i honestly think major the
dog just sees the evil in the government
dogs are good at that i'm a groomer pea
water dogs are stubborn but sweet ian
i want to slap everyone who's mean to
you lol oh be nice
so so the actual story is major the dog
is the hero
who's trying to fight against the evils
and the corruption
sounds like a comic book i don't like
this people that's not that's not nice
oh yeah definitely
morgan kowika says i joined the army
straight out of high school
but i had to prove that i was going to
do that bring a recruiter in with me
while college was basically being rammed
down my throat
interesting jonathan says
from your video earlier the problem goes
beyond physical altercations
the average age of firefighters
especially volunteers keeps going up as
the younger generations don't join the
fire service
yeah it's going to be a bunch of
youtubers yeah
how sad is that who would want to be a
youtuber worst
job ever you actually make money on
youtube i know it's not even a real job
no join the army join the fire
department don't be some guy who's in a
chair and complains in front of a camera
listen to my opinions i gotta be honest
yeah i would absolutely
say that a firefighter is very much more
important than the average youtuber oh
for sure but
the problem we have right now is that
trade jobs are being completely ignored
because
the younger generation is being told you
want to be a computer scientist or
something it's like dude
we need people who can fix toilets yeah
and you know it's funny when your toilet
breaks you will be on your knees begging
please show up today please show up
today and they're going to go
sorry we're booked we can be there
tomorrow and you're like no my toilet is
broken
ben's made this point ben townsend who
works with us he's uh our official
intelligence engineer more or less but
he's like
the things that we will still need are
manual trades that our fingers do
because we don't have computers that can
do those things yet like plumbing
electrician i just want to stress this
point
you might need a computer scientist you
might need a vlogger or a blogger
maybe people are saying tim you provide
a great service because you're helping
breakdowns information having very smart
conversations
but i will tell you this the moment your
toilet breaks you will be begging for a
plumber
at that moment look we've had we had we
had a condensation
you know happening on a pipe and it was
like dripping causing damage
and we're like this is really bad and we
call the
you know the the plumbing heating and
air and they're like we can be there in
three days yeah
and i'm like no one has ever screamed
out in fear like is there a critical
race theory
i need a youtuber i need a poetry major
quickly
um along that same things of of the the
learning to fix things etc the very
first question you got was that kid who
or younger person who said like what can
i do to get ready you said the survival
video yeah
i would also if i could say one thing
watch youtube videos don't play with
electricity if you don't know what
you're doing but try to fix things
yourself
yes that's the best advice i think i've
given young people i have so many
splinters on my hands from trying to fix
things on the farm they don't know what
i'm doing
you know like i said don't play with
electricity don't get yourself killed
but if something breaks even your toilet
and you're like i'm gonna try to fix it
i guarantee you there's a youtube video
see we love youtubers
try to fix things yourself it makes you
makes you feel like you've accomplished
something
why don't you learn stuff can we get
some firefighters to film and do a vlog
about being a firefighter
with gopros that'd be awesome think
about how amazing
that would be in terms of like content
now you want you can't you blur the
victims you don't show certain things
but explaining what goes on in the fire
department showing the fire poles and
the outfits explain what the outfits do
that there's got to be somebody even
like if there was a youtube channel
where it was just videos of them going
into fires
and you see their perspective and their
tactics you know why this probably not
is because it's
it's probably liability lawsuits right
they're they're
government employees they're probably
not allowed to be in the firehouse and
say hey guys here's what this does
here's what this was
but it would be great if they did i mean
i understand in the in the in the
firehouse we've had cops
yeah you know so we could film
firefighters going around and saving
people and doing that kind of stuff and
that would inspire people and everyone
likes firemen i mean like
seriously they're usually good-looking
and through on the south side of chicago
one of the oldest jobs of humanity fire
fighting on the south side people would
say don't call the cops call the fire
department
because a big fire truck pulling up with
the sirens blaring would usually
clear up conflicts altercations you know
if like a gang fight was happening
people would run and hide you call the
cops and it just goes crazy it goes
south and then yeah
so that's what people would say i'm not
saying it's the right thing to do become
a fireman you're like the biggest
recruiter now for the fighter
maybe they'll stay absolutely fire all
right brandon tom says rooster 2024
i gotta be honest like
if we had a rooster as the president at
least they would run full speed towards
putin and you know like flap their wings
at them and like kick at them
biden's gets come on man you think
china's gonna eat our lunch
come on man you're right look you put
joe biden
and xi jinping in a room and joe biden's
gonna be deferential that rooster is
gonna be going nuts
i mean you put anybody in the room with
the rooster the rooster goes after you
well i think one of the things they
hated about donald trump is that he did
point out who our enemies were and
people didn't want to hear that
it made them feel unsafe donald trump
was like a rooster he was a little bit
of a rooster
china is bad this huge immigration
problem is
bad right this is bad absolutely like
weird hair
i want someone who has like aviator
sunglasses and a puppy and that will
make me feel better
now the puppy's growing up to be a
full-blown dog and it's biting everybody
he's an ace
he looks like a fighter pilot he dresses
like one yeah all right
j rich says i think if a person is
actively on welfare they should be
disqualified from voting
as we've seen low info welfare voters
often vote for policies that are
ultimately to their detriment
sounds harsh but they need to be saved
from themselves
that's tough man i do think it makes
sense when we talk about
some kind of tie to the community is
require requirement for the vote
which would mean at the federal level
everybody always gets to vote at the
local levels the state level there would
be different requirements and
restrictions
but i mean it's it's a double-edged
sword
people have the right to vote and talk
about what their government does the
problem ultimately though is i don't
think any of these votes matter
like we know that special interests
sway public policy more than a welfare
voter wasn't there a study that came out
that congress followed this is like back
around occupy wall street the congress
would follow the will of the
corporations
of the wealthy individuals who who fund
they fundraise you know off of
so over the people absolutely that was
weird yeah
jason dunn says i also have a blue
healer goose 17 months
and he will be my guardian for life but
if you are weak or unattentive
he will see himself as the leader and
all bets are
are off for control it's pathetic that
they thought a german shepherd was a
good idea as a pr tactic
they could have they could hire a
trainer yeah they really you know what i
mean
tweet me a photo of goose i'd love to
see what he looks like they're beautiful
dogs but he's right there
they are not they're not french bulldogs
right
that's what people they're not they're
you have to constantly dominate them
and and and german shepherds even more
because at least blue healers are a
moderate size you know 45 50 pounds but
shepherds can be 75
85 they're big dogs and they're strong
they're attack dogs
yes i mean yeah and so it was crazy they
gave this man a german
shepherd unless and i will give him that
caveat he has had a history of raising
german shepherds
ahmed smith uh i'm sorry ahmed malih
says love watching the podcast while i
work out tim here's my obligatory fifty
dollars for you to read my resume
i'm applying as a writer you can find my
blog at ahmedmalid.com
hope to hear back from you soon love you
guys that was never a legitimate thing
that was a joke
you don't need to give us money resumes
or anything like that
and i have to say we like explicitly
will not look at resumes based on people
sending in super chats because some
people
you know yeah we're not yeah it's called
solicitation we're not doing that we're
not that
nice super chat dude you're getting
pumped to this that's i used to do it
with rogan
podcast i get so inspired i start doing
push-ups
you should watch i got a bunch of super
chats but you should watch carl
benjamin's
mini doc on venezuela and the history of
what happened
but uh ghost of recon says ian needs to
read the history of venezuela
instead of relying on the vox breakdown
chavez destroyed venezuela long before
the cia got involved or sanctions were
imposed
well i don't know how do you know that
the cia wasn't involved since the 70s
i don't know because maybe these people
have read the history and watched the
documentaries yeah but ci does
stuff that's called clandestine where no
one knows about it sure but i think at
this point the proper response would be
like i should watch those documents
i gotta go i got to educate myself in
venezuela
carl has a really really great one yeah
nice i remember uh
i was watching it on a road trip and it
was just like 40
40 minutes and i was like wow i used to
go deep i loved it
really good jeffrey grayjig says hugo
chavez was on a venezuelan late show
one night talking about soccer and
colombia got so upset he sent a tank
division to the colombian border
from the set of the show lunatic you
and they said trump was bad
people people are not happy with the
with the venezuela stuff let's take it
let's go with it
chavez was a nationalist populist
not necessarily great but
all right we'll read just a couple more
here casey finnegan says hey tim watched
your interview on joe rogan with jack
and his puppet
you totally shut them down also saw your
recent interview on fox great stuff hey
thank you very much yeah the fox thing
was funny they were like hey we wanna we
wanna have you on the show and i was
like
sorry man look i live in the middle of
nowhere i'm busy and they're like we
will send a truck to your house
and i was like what they're like yeah
it's a truck and i'm like
what it's a it's a it's a van
they open the side door and inside is a
chair with a tv behind you
they literally pull them in front of my
in front of my studio house parking lot
and i just climbed in and sat down and
there's a camera in front of me and i
was in this weird
it was cool it was like this little
weird little like soundproof room to
give me a beard piece
so we should build something like that
for the road trip mobile
yeah so we actually those that are
listening we actually are planning a uh
a tour set up we have a truck we've got
a 40-foot rv
where we can do this show and the goal
is at some point
go to nashville spend a week there then
do a friday night live show at a venue
then go to austin spend a week there
friday night live show to venue
then go back to you know i don't know
what the next city would be but another
city on the way and then a week later
make it back to home base
so uh yeah we probably could see we're
talking about media manipulation did you
see his fox video
i did yes there's something about that
like official
um what would you call it like spectacle
where like it's got the
it's got the thing in the background
that you're used to seeing it's got the
the bar across the bottom of the chiron
it made it look like he's got he arrived
he's arrived and people are like
i'm so glad you finally made it to the
big times and like i was legit i was on
tucker's show
i was on tucker carlson before but when
you see that spectacle it like
almost like brainwashes you to think
it's official actually
i've actually been on cable news like a
lot i've been on jesse waters show a lot
they used to have me on all the time
especially more so when i lived in the
new york area can i encourage you
on this road trip hit rural america also
cities are great it's just a city but
but even rural
you know i mean like i'm sure you've got
listeners right now who or watchers who
are going to say come to this small town
music center but small town america
is the heart of this country the issue
is mapping up connectivity
yeah so if we're so right right now
it took us months and months and months
but we finally got the strong you know
gigabit internet connection
ridiculously expensive to get rid of
gigabit mind you uh
if we go out to small towns and we're on
cell tech
cellular lines in order to do the show
you're dead well just lower quality yeah
i know that's a valid point but i'm
actually fairly confident we can find
areas where they'll have
20 to 30 megabits up or down yeah but
you know when i've driven across the
country before even to this day there
are a lot of areas that only get four
four or five megabits that's what i get
on my farm yeah
via satellite so not very good so i've
actually we've been looking into
satellite internet because satellite
internet we've actually used on this
show before when our internet's cut out
it automatically jumps over to the
satellite feed which is i think
like what is it five or six megabits up
yeah and that's
that's a that's good for a broadcast uh
it's not a safe amount but it's possible
and i'm like if we could get that
satellite
on the the rv we'd be good i just i've
looked at all these different companies
and they don't offer the speeds
for rv internet so we'd have to like
figure out some
stronger solution but uh let's just do
one more
super chat rg merkel says i was a
firefighter firefighter in north st
louis county during the ferguson riots
we were assisting ferguson fire
department when needed
we sadly kept firearms and body armor on
our fire truck for our safety
man that's sad i was there at those
fires man we were driving down the
street and you could feel the heat of
the fire through the car the fires were
so massive
it was insane wow the whole street west
florist and everything just lit up
every building fire we saw people
walking around with gas tanks with gas
cans sorry
you know and pouring it and lighting
things up yeah i remember there was some
cops walking by
and we watched someone light up some
garbage trying to burn a building down
and as the cops walking by i was like
hey yo they set a fire over here
and then a bunch of people got mad at me
and like whose side are you on
and they were like shut up what are you
doing you're gonna get us you're gonna
get beaten up and i was like
the cops are coming and to put a fire
out i don't know man like
i wanted to let them know there's a fire
that's crazy to me
they wanted the buildings to burn down
that was the right thing that's the
wrong thing
i'm not look i'm here reporting but like
someone sets a building down i'm gonna
be like yo like
you're like the paladin in the group in
d and d you're like i cannot allow evil
and you're like call it out even if it's
your own party members well they think
that they're evil
but i'm like i don't know what burning
down this building has to do with
anything and someone could be in there
and get hurt man yeah
but they wanted it so when i shut down
where was that i mean ferguson
dang yeah anyway my friends if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to this channel because we
will soon be breaking one million
subscribers and
youtube's gonna have to give us that
that that golden plaque or whatever yeah
and then you know shortly after it's
[Laughter]
listen we're talking about what's going
on with stephen crowder don't forget to
go to louder with crowder.com
and if you like a lot of crowder
obviously and and join monk club because
you know they're coming after him hard
and look it is it is one step at a time
if if crowder gets knocked off it's only
a matter of time until they come for us
and so you know we always for
independent media want to stay together
and so shout out to crowder
you know i'm sorry that you know this
all is all this bs is happening
but uh go to timcast.com as well become
a member because we're going to have a
bunch of original content
we're actually in starting the
conversations about doing original shows
i've had a conversation with a couple
comedians
about movies and funding full-on tv
shows
that we would produce for probably
timcast.com and actually just making
real content
to build that culture we uh we've we've
filmed some vlog content so far but we
should need to get to that point where
we're actually pumping it out and we're
going to bring on writers for
timcast.com so please become a member
help support the show
and you can follow me on social media at
tim cast my other youtube channels are
youtube.comtimcast and
youtube.comcastnews this show is live
monday through friday at 8pm so make
sure you tune in tomorrow because you
know
we'll be back and share this this
podcast really is the best thing you can
do just tell people to listen to it
help us grow and if you're listening on
itunes spotify leave us a good review
because that also really does help give
us five stars
and uh daniel you want to shout anything
out it's been awesome being with you um
great issues to talk about great
conversation and always a pleasure to be
here with you guys so thanks and
the com the people who said like what
you are doing for the culture cannot
emphasize that enough we need more
people doing this and so that's great
more voices you got a social media
account yeah so
powerthefuture.com if you care about
energy issues uh i am daniel turner ptf
on twitter um i think it's the same on
facebook instagram
um but yeah we talk about energy
environmental issues love to hear from
you if you have questions
and send me pictures of your blue healer
yeah all right i love you man thanks for
coming
um you guys i love you and your con i
really like
your comments i like you and thank you
for all the super chats i wish we could
get through more uh
they're really really entertaining and
enjoying to listen and thanks for
putting up with my dine travel in
venezuela i'm definitely going to look
into that because
it's probably one of the most pressing
issues on earth right now so something
that i'll probably educate ourselves
with you can follow me ian crossland.net
if you'd like to purchase a mug or other
things and check out all my socials from
there thanks again
and i'm sour patch lids and i will say
that i used to love listening to sargon
talk about history
he talks some about ancient history and
right now they're going through the
stoics so i especially love that that's
my
wheelhouse i'm sourpatchlids on twitter
and mines and real sourpatchlids on
instagram and gab
we will be back in about an hour with an
exclusive
members only segment over at timcast.com
so make sure you sign up and we will see
you all there
you